[Music]
two of our speakers this afternoon have
obligations elsewhere and need to get
out of here on time this has been just a
fascinating morning of history taught by
those who actually lived it we're going
to move on now to talk about a set of
issues related to the present and the
future but before we do since many of
you didn't live this history
I thought the I should yield to the
professor in me and offer a very short
list of suggested readings since this is
a topic on which there has been in fact
a great deal of academic endeavor we
heard already this morning about several
books that bill golden has edited the
most recent of which is called science
and technology advice to the President
Congress and judiciary it's a series of
essays by more or less everyone who
spoke this morning plus a large number
of others
another nice discussion of many of the
issues we heard about this morning was a
book by Greg her concordant Isis
presidential science advising from the
atomic bomb to SDI and it picks up the
theme that was present in many of this
morning's discussions about the very
large role that defense and Cold War
considerations have played through much
of the science advice of that period
third on my list of four is a book by
Bruce Smith the advisors scientists in
the policy process which is broader than
just presidential science advising it
also talks about things like defense
Science Board and EPA science advisory
board but has a chapter on White House
Science advice and finally a lovely new
book which makes a very good
companion to hunter decrees classic on
that took science technology policy up
to about the time of the second world
war is a book by David Hart forged
consensus science technology and
economic policy in the United States
1921 to 1953
now it's also a great pleasure that
those some of you have figured out
what's going on here Morgan is stalling
a few minutes to get to get more
audience into the rooms for our speakers
but it's also a great pleasure to be
here at MIT at this function convened by
the Technology Policy program the first
of what I believe is plan to be a series
of functions of this sort in the years
to come
technology policy program here has
become part now of a larger
organizational group this engineering
systems division which incorporates a
number of policy and also management
related activities under one
cross-cutting umbrella that cuts across
the several departments of the
engineering college and those of us who
have worked in this area for a long time
and observe activities at MIT are really
rooting for this to be a big success
because to the extent things succeed at
MIT they will succeed in many other
places TPP was built through 24 years of
enormous effort and dedication by
Richard to new field and a number of
colleagues and it's now as you heard
this morning in the very capable hands
of Dan hasting this morning Chuck vest
described TPP as quote the largest
program of its kind it is the largest
master's program in this field though as
a guest here I guess I have to be
well-behaved I can't resist noting that
the Department of Engineering and public
policy at Carnegie Mellon has the
largest undergraduate program the
largest doctoral program and the largest
interdisciplinary tenured faculty in
this area
all right well I've stalled long enough
we've got about half the audience back
so let me do three quick introductions
this session is called cross-cutting
issues and the first speaker is Rita
Colwell she's going to talk to the topic
the human capital crisis in science and
engineering dr. Cole while obtained a
multidisciplinary education in
bacteriology genetics and oceanography
she's had a very distinguished academic
career at Georgetown University and at
the University of Maryland she's a
member of the National Academy and has
held many important positions and served
on many advisory in many advisory
capacities including services a member
of the National Science Board President
of the triple-s and a number of others
and she currently directs the National
Science Foundation the second speaker
this afternoon will be William wolf and
his topic is a new engineering ethics
great achievements and grand challenges
dr. Wolf's formal education was in
engineering physics Electrical
Engineering and computer science his
distinguished career has included a tour
on the faculty at Carnegie Mellon
University time spent as CEO of tartan
laboratories and time on the faculty of
the University of Virginia from where
she's currently on leave serving as
president of the National Academy of
Engineering and the third talked this
afternoon in this session is by Dan
Hastings who's going to talk about
technology and policy education needs
Chuck vest has already given you a
rather full introduction for professor
Hastings who holds a PhD in aeronautics
and Astronautics and after a
distinguished tourist chief scientist of
the air force has recently returned as I
said to a faculty position at MIT that
involves appointments both in aero-astro
and as head of the Technology Policy
program and the newly created
engineering systems division
[Applause]
good afternoon it's a genuine honor to
join all of you today and my thanks go
to chuck fasst and daniel hastings for
inviting me and to MIT for hosting all
of us before I start my talk I'd like to
point out just how hot off the press is
on the NSF strategy in brief if any of
you are interested I've left a few
copies on the table it simply describes
how NSF operates our strategic goals and
our core strategies well there's no
question that OSTP has been vital to our
nation's scientific and technological
advancement just as was mentioned this
morning
just as Merlin used his great visionary
powers to counsel King Arthur on the
affairs of Camelot each science advisor
has done a magical job advising our
presidents on Science and Technology
Policy and the variations of the theme
have been fascinating to listen to the
OSTP directors have brought a very rich
and diverse set of perspectives to the
position ultimately steering our nation
in a direction that's enhanced the
growth and development of our society
our economy and most of all humanity
it's fitting that we address the topic
of the human capital crisis in science
and engineering attracting women and
minorities into these fields has been a
concern of mine for some time and so
I've titled my remarks confronting the
human capital crisis tapping the talent
I will talk about the future of the
Science Engineering and Technology
workforce though I do think that thus
charts we saw this morning comparing
electrical engineering and Parks and
Recreation and related subjects was
pretty pretty dramatic if not
devastating then I'd like to talk a
little bit about what NSF is doing
through its efforts of recruiting women
and minorities and its k12 programs to
develop the workforce
and this is an issue that is critical to
all of us
it's been a theme running through many
of the talks this morning
and NSF it's the very core of our vision
and our mission the National Science
Foundation is as much about preparing a
world-class workforce as it is about
discovery although we continually break
new ground through the research and the
education we support we need people to
turn that new knowledge into innovation
now worrisome signals about the science
engineering and technology workforce are
much too familiar we've heard of the
shortages of skilled workers that have
plagued the IT the information
technology sector and the numbers of
computer scientists coming out 800 or so
that's that's appalling well here are
some other data while degrees in
engineering physical sciences and math
and computer sciences are either static
or declining as we have seen other
nations of boosting degrees in all these
fields carrying a little bit further
from the data that was provided in the
charts let me put it another way a 24
year old in Japan for example is three
times more likely to hold a bachelor's
degree in engineering than a 24 year old
in the United States in the recent
studies report that graduate enrollments
in science and engineering have
increased in the US for the first time
in a decade unfortunately that's the
good news the bad news is the growth is
almost entirely the result of an
increase in the number of foreign
students graduate enrollment in these
fields among US students has continued
to decline from 1986 to 1997 bachelor's
degrees in mathematics declined by
approximately 30% from 16,000 or so to
about 12 or so thousand since 1998 the
number of doctoral degrees awarded in
science and engineering dropped 5% there
was a slight uptick in the in 1999 but
that was doing
entirely two foreign student enrollment
well the lesson that we should take from
these examples is not that we should
discourage foreign students it's about
tapping the full range of the nation's
native-born science and engineering
talent we're simply not producing enough
workers trained in science math in
engineering to meet the needs of today's
technology based society and that's
where the crisis is I quote from a
report released in January by the u.s.
Commission on national security for the
21st century I'm sure that most of you
are familiar with it and it states very
bluntly the inadequacies of our systems
of research and education posed a
greater threat to US national security
over the next quarter century than any
potential conventional war we might
imagine very strong words if ever there
were any question about the nation's
need to develop its science and
engineering talent this should banish
all doubts well what should we be doing
about this situation the title of
another recent report suggests an answer
it's land of plenty diversity as
America's competitive edge in science
engineering and technology that report
it provides the findings of a
congressional Commission on the
advancement of women and minorities in
science engineering and technology we
referred to it as the comset report it
was chaired by representative Marella
from Maryland and it was co-chaired by
representative Eddie Bernice Johnson
from Texas it issues a very clear call a
warning we are making some strides to it
including everyone in the general
workforce although we do have a distance
to go but there's some progress
unfortunately we're not making
significant progress in changing the
composition of the science and
engineering workforce
it still looks mighty exclusive well
Palance of my children it's Pale Male
and they would say stale but I didn't
say their although white males make up
about 42% of the US workforce they
constitute nearly 70% of a science
engineering and technology workforce
women of all races and ethnicities make
up only 15% of the SNT the science
engineering technology workforce
african-americans and hispanics of both
genders male and female account for
about 3% each the general workforce
already reflects much more gender equity
equality and racial and cultural
diversity projections show that growth
in the u.s. labor force through 2008
will come mostly from women and
minorities the growth will come from
expanding the pool of science and
engineering talent and we need the
talent of every worker in order to
compete and prosper that expansion must
come from the mostly untapped potential
of underrepresented women minorities and
women and I'd like to say that that in
fact represents America's competitive
edge for the 21st century the National
Science Foundation is committed to
building a science and engineering
workforce that's inclusive and draws on
all the talent in the nation and in fact
people don't really view the NSF as a
people agency we fund 200,000 people
every year 70 or 80 thousand teachers 35
to 40 thousand graduate students
undergraduate students high school
students faculty and various programs
that is not even to mention those that
are touched by the IMAX films public
radio broadcasts and so forth which
reaches out to about 50 million people
I'd like to tell you a little bit about
some of the things we're doing it in SF
to address this issue I'll begin with
recruitment of women and minorities
science and engineering and then I'll
talk about the k-12 education programs
one of the newest programs at the
National Science Foundation went on the
web just a month ago addresses the very
small numbers of women in science and
engineering
it's called advance the program intends
to catalyze system-wide changes in
universities that is to induce change in
the universities and colleges that will
foster a more positive climate for women
to pursue academic careers in advance
also aims to bring more women into
science and engineering it addresses
what we in elegantly referred to as the
two-body problem or the trailing spouse
and that is to provide an opportunity
for funding for women who are returning
to the workforce or who are moving
because of their husband has taken a
position in another institution it's an
opportunity for them to have funding in
order to move with with the spouse and
it's also open to men for women who have
spouses of women who have received
position in an institution that allows
them the husband to apply since he's
part of a two-body problem the message
is that NSF values and rewards the hard
work needed to change the conditions for
women in science and engineering and
this will give participants an
opportunity to make a real difference
over the long term now I'd also like to
mention the louis stokes alliances for
minority participation these alliances
target the under-representation of
minorities and science and engineering
it's about 10 years old the program
links two and four-year educational
institutions with business industry and
government and there are now about 28
alliances across the United States now
key features of the success include a
summer bridge program to help high
school graduates prepare for college as
well as provide them with research
experiences and mentoring a study done
by the National Science Board back in
nineteen
eighty-eight shows that one of the most
powerful karlitz of success in science
and engineering measured by a senior
position or success you know price of
Nobel Prize our last grew order full
professorship or whatever is the
opportunity to do research in a
laboratory with a mentorship being
provided
now the programs have made a real impact
on the number of degrees awarded to
minorities in the Alliance institutions
in 1990 before the program began degrees
in the first group of institutions the
two-year institutions totaled under
4,000 by the year 2000 this had
increased to more than 7,000 for all of
the Alliance institutions the total by
the year 2000 last year was over 21,000
degrees a number that continues to grow
and I would say that success by any
measure
I should also want to score that NSF's
largest investment in women and minority
scientists and engineers is through our
ongoing research and education efforts
NSF support for women researchers for
example has tripled over the last decade
to about 500 million dollars about half
a billion dollars we still have a long
way to go I certainly would admit that
but we are reaching out and cashing in
on the talents and skills of many more
of our citizens now another area where
we need to do a better job tapping the
nation's talent is with a k12 science
and math education here's where
attracting more women and minorities to
bolster the SME workforce really begins
today however far too many girls women
minorities fail even to cross the
threshold into science and engineering
we know that there are lots of obstacles
and stereotyped cultural conditioning
that begins to appear very early in life
and we refer to the grades between 4 & 8
as the valley of death
and interestingly not only for girls but
also for boys where the interest that's
so keen in the first few grades in
science engineering discovery wings and
is socially sort of dissuasive now I've
often told the story of how when I was
in high school girls were simply not
allowed to take physics yes that's true
more to the point my high school
chemistry teacher told me I'd never make
it in chemistry girls couldn't do
chemistry later on in life as an
undergraduate student and I won't say
we're applying for a graduate fellowship
my department chair said that he didn't
waste fellowships on women well today no
one would ever say outright they would
not waste a fellowship on a woman yet
when we consider how to attract women
and minorities to science and technology
we really have to begin by reexamining
our assumptions about education across
the board from kindergarten to lifelong
learning and this is an absolute
imperative for today's children if
they're going to participate
successfully in the workforce of
tomorrow and yet too many of them leave
science and technology and just abandon
it before they leave high school this is
all part of a much larger challenge most
of us are familiar with the results of
the third international mathematics in
science study better known as Tim's it's
become almost a mantra
unfortunately the study compared the
average performance of US students to
students in other countries although US
fourth graders performed above average
in the study performance declined by
eighth grade and by the 12th grade u.s.
students were right at the bottom the
most recent team study repeated only for
the eighth graders was released just a
month ago in Washington we had a press
conference it gives us some reason to be
hopeful but it still shows a long way to
go because some of the individual school
districts made it to the top of the
international rankings and so that
suggests that yes we can raise the
performance of US children through
improvements in the quality of k-12
education
now we at NSF are really pleased that
the president has asked us to lead the
math and science partnerships called the
No Child Left Behind education
initiative at the center of NSF's FY
2002 budget request is 200 million
dollars of a five-year 1 billion dollar
of me investment and this will be used
to strengthen and reform k12 science and
math education in ACEF will provide
funds for the states and the local Duke
school districts to join with
institutions of higher learning for
example the local school districts in
Boston with MIT the goal is to help
ensure that all k-12 students have the
opportunity to perform to high standards
in science and math and we're asking
scientists mathematicians engineers at
universities and colleges to work with
educators in the elementary middle and
high schools to achieve some very
ambitious goals the partnerships
programs aims to strengthen mass math
and science standards to improve
curricula in textbooks and to raise the
quality of teacher professional
development bringing research
experiences into the classroom really
should help improve student achievement
but the program doesn't end just there
we hope to eliminate the performance gap
between minority and majority students
and reach underserved schools and
students in creative new ways well let
me point out just one other program
that's very important it's been proven
very successful and that's our G k-12
program graduate student k12 involvement
the program works with having an
individual scientist and institution or
an engineer in higher education
institution partnering with a teacher in
the elementary middle or high school and
developing a program to enhance science
and math education funding goes to
graduate students they receive a stipend
of
$18,000 and we hope with the new money
provided in our budget to raise the
stipend to 20,000
five hundred dollars though for the
graduate students in the audience we
would like to raise it to $25,000 in any
case this provides an opportunity for
the student who receives a stipend it
has grant fees and tuition covered to
then spend twenty hours a week with a
school teacher in the elementary middle
or high school providing the content the
mentorship and the excitement of the
research and perhaps school children
will learn that engineers do things
besides drive trains well let me stop
here I look forward to a bit of
discussion my simple message is one of
always pushing ahead constant
improvement meeting ever tougher
challenges we've made some tremendous
steps forward across our society in some
areas science and technology has
inspired the progress that we have made
in other areas we've trailed now we can
change that and I know that all of us
are committed to making a difference
thank you
[Applause]
the thing that concerns me is what about
the other end is it realistic to think
even at the k-12 level that unless
people can see a secure future in the
sense that if you get a good education
and do well that there'll be a good job
for you
is it realistic to think that people
will flow into these fields for instance
I think we may have a crisis in
biological sciences because we already
have an enormous oversupply of people in
post aqua positions that may not be
oversupply compared to some measure of
demand but it is compared to jobs and so
if someone looking hard at what we do at
the job end well there's a very serious
anomaly on the one hand we were
increasing h-1b visas to bring in nearly
200,000 people technically trained from
other countries fifty-five thousand from
India alone from the Indian Institute of
Technology and other very productive
institutions there at a time that now we
are seeing a cascade and job
opportunities in other words we cannot
address our needs for Science and
Technology talent by importation it
doesn't work what we need to do is
reflect on how we are educating and in
fact duty to produce students who
graduate who are flexible and who will
be prepared as they must to to to have
seven or eight career changes before
retirement you and I could expect to
stay in one one job or one one kind of
for example a microbiologist and I'm
still doing microbiology that isn't
going to happen for those who graduate
this this spring and so we need to to
not only focus on how we're teaching our
students but also in what we're teaching
them and then for the expectations that
we are providing them we do have a
tremendous need for mathematicians
across all of society I don't think we
will have a glut even
if we are successful in the push that
we're making to put more money into
mathematics I could go on and on for an
hour about that I won't okay thanks
Ranger I want to add my thanks to to
Chuck and Dan for hosting this
anniversary celebration symposium I
think this is a this is really nifty and
to get so many of the former science
advisors here at the same time is really
pretty
pretty special when Dan asked me to
speak today he asked me to in essence
repeat the talk that I gave at the
annual meeting of the National Academy
of Engineering last fall and so in some
sense this is going to be an abbreviated
version of that the talk the full talk
tried to first talk about the kinds of
contributions that engineering has made
to our quality of life and the second
half was to look forward and ask what
are the challenges facing engineering
for the 21st century I'm gonna lop off
the first self-congratulatory part of
the talk altogether and I'm going to
focus in on just one challenge for the
21st century a challenge that I think
may be the greatest one that we have to
face and it is in fact engineering
ethics now what then didn't tell me was
that I was going to be talking right
after Harold Shapiro talked about ethics
he was vaguely apologetic about not
being a scientist I'll be vaguely
apologetic about not being an ethicist
as well I want to start out by making it
clear that I believe that engineers and
engineering by and large are very
ethical there are
courses and engineering ethics at many
universities there's a a stack about two
two and a half feet high of books that
have been written just in the last five
years on the question of engineering
ethics abet mm the the criteria by which
engineering schools are accredited
require an exposure to ethics at least
in the context of a capstone project and
every single engineering Society has a
professional code of ethics the one that
most of them are modelled on is from the
National Society of Professional
Engineers and it starts out saying that
engineers will hold paramount the health
and safety of the public and then goes
on in in great detail some 170 or so
separate points of specific
responsibilities that engineers have to
their customers to the public and so on
so with all of that in place why did I
try and tell the Academy that that I
thought one of the greatest challenges
for the 21st century was engineering
ethics it's because I think the practice
of engineering is changing and changing
in a way that raises new kinds of
ethical issues ones that engineers at
least haven't had to face before the
existing codes of the vast majority of
the books the context in which the abet
requirement is written all deal with
what is known as micro ethics I don't
mean micro to being small or unimportant
but rather ethics that have to do with
the behavior of an individual as opposed
to macro ethics which deal with the
behavior of the profession as a whole
perhaps illustrating the point with
another field will will help in medicine
the ethical codes that a doctor
subscribes to for his or her individual
behavior
bear an amazing resemblance to the
engineering ethical codes the behavior
of the individual is specified in very
similar ways but medicine has had to
deal with some of these macro ethical
problems which engineering have not has
not the most the easily most easily
accessible example is allocation if
there are less organs to transplant than
there are patients who need them how do
we decide which patient gets them that's
not a decision for the individual doctor
similarly if there's less medicine than
the number of people ill or if there's
simply less time for the physician to
allocate to all of the people who are
ill how do you do triage how do you
decide who gets who gets the attention
and who does not
again those are macro ethical questions
because they're questions that either
the the profession has to decide upon or
perhaps better society informed by the
profession needs to decide well I said
engineering is changing the practice of
engineering is changing in ways that
raise these macro ethical problems I'm
gonna focus on just one such change
again in the interest of time and that's
the issue of complexity particularly
complexity arising from information
technology from biotechnology and
perhaps in the near future
from nanotechnology simple fact is it is
possible today to build systems for
which it is impossible to predict all of
their behaviors a priori it's not just
hard it's not just if you thought about
it more you could do it it is literally
impossible perhaps the best way I can
illustrate that is from my own field in
computing we've got some physicists in
the audience and so maybe somebody can
give me the exact number but I believe
that their kind of order of 10 to the
100th
elementary particles in the universe I'm
looking at Allan Bromley to tell me
that's right
okay saying is it's it's 10 raise to 1
followed by a couple of digits maybe it
120 I want you to compare that to the
number of states in my laptop by state I
simply mean the number of patterns of
ones and zeros in my laptop that number
is 10 raised to 10 to the 20th power so
whereas a number of atoms in the
universe is 10 to the 1 followed by two
zeros the number of states in my laptop
is 10 raised to 1 followed by 2003
atom in the universe were a computer and
every one of them could do 10 to the
100th operations per second there isn't
enough time since the Big Bang to
examine all of the states in my laptop
ok that's the sense in which I mean we
can build systems that are so
complicated that you it is impossible to
predict their behavior it's not that
there isn't an algorithm which given
enough time puddings could determine all
of the outcomes all of the behaviors
it's that there isn't enough time very
concrete example of this was a report
issued by the Naval Research Lab which
one of my areas of research has been
computer security over the years and
there was an NRL report about 1993 if I
remember correctly that looked at the
reasons for about 50 security failures
lapses and security that happened
because the way these 50 were example
worse 50 examples were selected the the
numbers I'm not about to give are not
necessarily representative of anything
but of those 50 examples
twenty-two were errors in the
specifications errors in the sense that
a property which was thought to be
essential for the correct behavior of
the system in fact turned out to be the
vehicle by which somebody could crack
the system every case it was because the
particular way that the cracking was
done was not anticipated for exactly the
reasons I'm describing the system is too
complicated it's impossible to predict
its behavior so the question then is how
does one behave ethically in such cases
what does it mean to ethically engineer
when you know that the system that you
build will be had we'll have behaviors
that you did not predict some of which
might be negative some of which might be
absolutely disastrous and in fact we
have to begin to rethink the process by
which we engineer I mean the the kind of
standard process you're taught in
engineering school is that somebody
gives you a specification for a problem
for a solution to a problem you go find
a design that effects that solution you
build it you test it go home well I'm
sorry the error is going to be back in
the specification or the problem is
going to be back in the specification so
how do we modify the process by which we
behave I think there's no better example
right at the moment then people are
talking about remediation of the
Everglades we're about to do some
multibillion-dollar re-engineering of
the Everglades let me tell you that's
one of these complicated systems for
which we will not be able to predict the
consequences of what we do and yet doing
nothing is not an acceptable solution
either doing nothing is also a conscious
decision and it will have consequences
so how do we ethically engineer in such
a circumstance I've got another example
but I we're gonna run out of time and so
let me defer that to any questions
or defer that to questions at the end
I wish Herald were still here
you might get into a more interesting
conversation thank you
[Applause]
although we can't like say in the case
of the Everglades we have some idea what
will happen over small period of time of
course we don't have large periods of
time and how would you how would how
would you think about that specify a
little when design a little and build a
little and test a little and then go
back and ask what's happen but that's
that's a much more organic interaction
with whatever it is that you're
producing then engineers are accustomed
to the question of large numbers and the
impossibility of specifications isn't it
a question partly of how and what you
specify ordinary statistical mechanics
is a way of dealing with very very large
numbers maybe only 10 to the 30th rows
and a hundredth
but most most of the states become
outliers on a distribution for which
certain macroscopic barriers variables
can be fine fun I will let in most of
the situations one encounters take care
of them I mean if one can one deal
similarly statistically with these large
numbers let's see in the case of
continuous systems maybe the trouble
with with digital systems is that
they're not continuous a one bit change
can lead you to a state which which has
no relationship to the state you changed
from you don't have continuity and
it's a problem and we've talked about
micro and macro and I and everybody
applauds what you and others are doing
in a big macro picture sense from a
national point of view if there is a
crisis as your title says and and there
is including the workforce minorities
women and and human beings what in a
big-picture sense can we try to do to
bring some elevation of political
awareness so that there's policy action
on this critical critical issue
[Music]
education is the number one priority for
the country I think what we need to do
is ensure that we take advantage of this
wonderful opportunity when there is a
focus on k-12 education and I think the
big problem has been the disconnect I
call it the scorched earth between the
elementary middle and high school and
the higher education somehow we have
risen above it which is sort of bizarre
and we need to reconnect and it is our
problem and I think if we can take
advantage of this this really excellent
opportunity in time that we have we can
make a big difference I really do and I
really worry about simplistic solutions
they're not simple solutions one of the
things we would like to do and I'm going
to give you a little commercial here is
establish centers focused on the science
of learning and teaching and to develop
these centers just as we so successfully
did for engineering research centers in
science and technology centers they were
a big they are a big success where we
require the industry local school system
higher education the community
preeminent and private foundations to be
partners in totally responsible provide
opportunities regionally for teachers to
read
their professionalism to regain their
pride of profession and then to have a
place to go to for the best practices
curricula etc anyway yeah Rita I'm sorry
I came in on just on the tail end of
your talk but I know what's in it so
it's not I've heard it before but the
question I have for you is this if you
remember back in the mid 1980s the
National Science Board and the National
Science Foundation made a big pitch for
increased numbers of scientific and
technical personnel if we had followed
through with that we would have not had
quite as bad a decline as we've had I
mean the timing was absolutely correct
however the political system beat us to
death and the reason that I know so well
is I was in on the National Science
Board at some time in chair at one time
over in that period of time and we
literally got slaughtered that's the
only word I can say for it and the
reason we did was that we had a small
recession which lasted for a year or two
and a few chemistry PhDs were driving
taxicabs and we just got killed
now the problem you have is we're now
looking at an economy which is not as
robust as it was this time last year and
the issue my concern is that we're going
to end up with the same kind of response
and if we do then the next time around I
mean it will simply be now twice as bad
as it was the time before how do we keep
people to understand that this is not a
response to whatever is doing today and
interestingly enough I have to say this
in the 1985-86 problem the universities
did not help us that's true well Mary
there is a difference today from from
that unhappy period of time which I
remember so well because I too was on
the science board with you as you will
remember the difference is that we have
had an attitude in the past which served
as well that we which we would educate
the best and the brightest and they
would lead us and they did into the
future as the
best in our fields the difference now is
that the technological work skill
demands are across the board and so in
order to be an auto mechanic you've got
to know mathematics you have to know
something about computers in fact you
have to know about computers because
they're probably 20 or 30 of them under
the hood so I think we have a different
kind of challenge than we did at that
time and also when you try to predict
directions of you if you try to predict
for kids where they will go that is a
mistake again
changing education so that we educate
kids who will be lifelong learners who
will be self educated and of course
distance education as MIT is doing so
well in making available its curricula
another way of educating that's very
very important in a new century so there
are differences there's a great deal of
complaining about the lack of people
moving into science and technology but I
would suggest there's no real economic
evidence that that is a problem you are
not finding the kinds of salaries for
engineers that are being paid for MBAs
going into consulting companies and so
when a company president complains to me
about the shortage of engineers and I
said well would you pay as much as you
do for the top MBAs he says well of
course we couldn't do that and there you
are
well that's anecdotal and it's valid but
let me counter with an anecdote as well
a friend of mine who's an African
American mathematician was he finished
his PhD early last year before the the
h-1b visas were full were completely
exhausted they were all taken and he
could not get a job but as soon as the
last of the visa h-1b visas were gone
then he had several job offers so I
think there is something very important
it's there that we are not looking to
our Native Americans we're not providing
the job opportunities and we're using an
artificial source for filling the jobs
that are very important and the IT jobs
do pay sixty percent more than the
average wage so they're not exactly
crummy jobs so to speak
no in fact that that that's that's
something that ought to be very
disturbing to us a new engineer with a
BS degree gets from fifty to a hundred
percent more than a person graduating
with a BA degree on average and yet we
in the face of that we're still losing
market share we're still getting a
smaller and smaller fraction of those
people who who do enter college who even
have the appropriate math and science
prerequisites opting not to take
engineering
[Applause]
well to finish up this session which was
to look at some of the cross-cutting
issues that are affecting the human
capital in this country I want to talk a
bit about the need for an integrative
technology and policy education I
subtitle this bridging the gap and the
question I want to address today it was
actually framed by Donald Kennedy I
thought very well in this insightful
book academic duty and in the final
chapter he asks the question can the
universities really make a difference
with respect to the big problems facing
us and in the in the actual chapter that
the big problems is capitalized which I
can't quite say that he suggests that
the list of challenges facing us ranged
from arms proliferation and disarmament
to ethical issues in genetic testing and
counseling as we heard today at lunch to
utilization incentives and healthcare
systems and these issues are indeed
intellectually exciting and analytically
demanding however the problem is that
they do not come in disciplinary
packages and furthermore he asserts in
his book those who wish to work on them
faced suspicion in the Academy which he
asserts tems partly from the traditional
academic reluctance to do applied work
and partly from the considerable
difficulty of being an interdisciplinary
scholar and he points out the critiques
often heard in these messes that it's so
valuable to go to the critique of those
who engage in interdisciplinary workers
often their work is watered down or
somehow has gone soft and therefore it's
hard to encourage people academics to
actually think hard about some of these
issues
he points out however that these issues
are indeed real and complex and their
problems of large scale and they need
the attention of thoughtful
intellectuals so then the question is he
frames in the last chapter his book
is whether the Academy can overcome the
resistance of departmental structure to
reengineer itself in the face of these
challenges and in this talk what I want
to argue that part of the answer to this
big question lies in educating leaders
flowing out of a new vision of
engineering - it's to some extent you
heard from from Bill wolf and his
emphasis on engineering ethics this new
vision of engineering is going to
operate at the interface of technology
and policy now in terms of building that
argument I first want to argue that we
live in a world of two cultures well I
think we've heard quite a bit about that
already today
and secondly in a world of accelerating
technological change with profound
social consequences and president
Shapiro made a very good case for some
of the the consequences in terms of the
the stories that guide us in our lives
here and thirdly I'm going to argue that
the paradigm for Engineering is changing
I'm from when this new paradigm can
emerge the kind of leaders that can
transform the Academy if we allow it to
actually happen the first thing to
consider of course is is here in the in
the first part of the 21st century of
modern day America we see a staggering
technological change in innovation so
the reality is even though as
representative Porter pointed out many
in the in the Congress may not entirely
appreciate the worlds of science and
technology our lives have been
fundamentally transformed by science and
technology it's hard to for those people
who are much older and you talk to
people much older you compare people to
lives today it's hard to understand the
the dimension of the changes so I even
talked to my own sons who live in a
world with has always been CDs and VCRs
and transatlantic phone calls and they
just don't think of anything else now
that level of communication has just
changed their lives in ways that they
don't even completely appreciate now an
awful lot of that of course has flowed
from the success of what's occurred in
the Academy a lot of the inventions and
Discovery's not all of them have flowed
from the Academy and in that sense they
a disciplinary formulation has proven to
be you've got to say on the basis of the
evidence remarkably successful however
we still live in a world of two cultures
many people as its representative Porto
suggested who end up in leadership come
up through a liberal arts education the
liberal arts education very correctly
emphasizes the human condition but gives
relatively little shrift to the
increasing scientific and technological
forces which are changing our
understanding of the world many of the
people who end up with this liberal arts
education end up in law and public
policy positions which which teaches
them very well to articulate their cases
but but does not teach him very well
fundamentally if they're talking about
Science and Technology exactly what
they're actually arguing about sometimes
this leads to amusing results and
sometimes worse what was very
interesting to observe in reading about
the the voting issues in Florida was the
debates over voting machines whereas
those of us trained in more of the
technocratic tradition would have said
well there's a fundamental issue about
uncertainty here which is fundamentally
unresolvable but but it was just hard to
get that point across to people by
contrast many like myself who've been
educated through a scientific education
and with a technocratic view of the
world which often does not take account
of the role of human beings I thought
that one of the ways to understand what
president Shapiro said at lunchtime
today was to tool it to hear the fact
that he was articulating a view where
where human stories are at the centre of
the way that human beings actually think
and often in a technocratic view of the
world that it's just it's just not clear
that people understand that now this
leads to the constant amazement as
scientists and engineers have that the
exposition of the data is insufficient
to convince policymakers
they just don't understand most
scientists and engineers the the nature
of stakeholders the problem of the
Commons and they typically have very
little interest or patience with the
necessary political process of course
this is not true of the steam gentlemen
sitting here I'm sure do you understand
the nature of the Commons and and
stakeholder interests so thus we find
ourselves in a society where where we
have this this divide not the only
divide but certainly one of the divides
where large segments of the public
either do not trust or understand the
the advances of science and technology
and many technologists do not understand
the public or the real constraints that
decision-makers actually face so I
suggest here the ongoing controversies
over genetically modified foods the
concerns over the spread of ubiquitous
networked computing the loss of privacy
as well as global climate change they
have many dimensions about them but
certainly some of the dimensions are due
to the fact that you have two different
more than two but certainly two
different groups of people who come from
very different positions on these things
I'm very different ways of understanding
the world two issues are very important
for leaders to understand and articulate
one is public mistrust of certain but
not all types of scientific or
engineering advances for example GMOs
but for example not for example personal
computers most people accept the notion
of personal computers may may not accept
the notion of networked personal
computers but it certainly puts the
computers they accept another issue that
that leaders have to understand
articulated is the role of objective
scientific analysis in addressing policy
decisions or problems for example global
warming HIV mercury contamination and
fish and so on now some of the issues
that arise arise from from perceptions
of scientists and engineers it's very
interesting it you can tell a lot about
a culture by going and looking at the
things they have on television and
having in movies and it's I find it's
insightful to look at some of the images
of scientists and engineers as as seen
in televisions
movies much of the time scientists and
engineers are seen as wizards so I
thought it was interesting
jakie worse description that he was he
was known as the presidents Merlin as
somebody who does this wizardry that you
don't quite understand but nevertheless
it turns out to be important to life so
much of the time scientists in NGOs seen
as Wizards able to work wonders that
people cannot see understand I mean just
look at some of the movies that and and
TV shows that people actually watch and
you see this happen again and again
generally speaking the wonders are good
for society but sometimes they require
others to help scientists and engineers
make the right decisions
this accelerating rate of change in
science and technology we see in our
lives around us combined with this lack
of understanding on both sides then
leads to situations of the public is
distrustful of science the technology
and where policy is often dragged into
reactive positions sometimes these
positions are correct
sometimes they reflect ignorance and
fear sometimes the politics and
competing values which cause
policymakers to hide or ignore
scientific evidence now for example
perhaps with coal-fired power plants
these these the continued divides and
society combined with the urgency of the
issues facing us I'm going to argue
suggesting a need for both research and
education that bridges the divide in
part what is needed is the kind of
integrative education in the Academy and
research that will produce individuals
who can lead and understand at the
interface of Science and Technology and
society and articulate the cases the
case to both sides of the divide so that
is they must have a foot in both sets of
wills this brings me the role that
accelerating technological change
actually plays in these issues these
integrative leaders I'm going to argue a
NIDA to actually help society deal with
accelerating change accelerating
technological changes fundamentally
transforming the way in which we
actually live over the last few decades
we've seen the introduction of lots of
new technologies range
from consumer plastics and TV to desktop
computing and the Internet these have
exerted profound influences on our
lifestyles and the ethical and material
development of our science and polity I
mean I think we again heard that today
at lunch and if the past is any prologue
the issues surrounding emergence of new
technologies will be even more profound
than in recent decades so I again I cite
innovations in the field genetic
engineering nanotechnology ubiquitous
computing as and so on as globalization
of these technologies continues to
deepen and accelerate it's going to
become increasingly difficult to
anticipate and address the political and
ethical issues as well as a cultural
societal issues before that we are swept
up them up in them in a reactive kind of
way and that's because of the
accelerating rate of change so the task
then of improving understand
understanding and of responding to rapid
innovation is inherently difficult its
marked by uncertainty over technical
advances uncertainty with respect to the
side effects on our natural and economic
systems and and uncertainty in the in
the political and cultural responses to
them too often the assessments of
technological advances begin with
with speculation before the fact that's
based on an inadequate understanding of
science to be followed by speculations
after the fact of what could have
actually been done better as a result
discussions tend to oscillate and you
can see this very clearly if you read
the op-ed pages of the papers
discussions tend to oscillate on the
implications of advancing technologies
tend to oscillate between techno
optimism so some of you may recall
electricity which will be too cheap to
meter and technophobia well you a great
deal of fear is expressed about the
appropriate technology until finally
after a period of oscillation more
realistic appraisals emerge and and then
some kind of policies actually set into
place
these any new technology I'm gonna argue
has the potential for consequences
beyond what beyond those that are
considered when it is actually developed
because our knowledge of the future can
never be perfect it means that we
actually have to start thinking about
the implications of the science and
technology we do as we are in the
process of actually doing it and I'm
going to argue again that we need the
kind of of integrative leaders who can
do that kind of thinking as the science
and technology is actually being
developed the the circumstances then so
ok so let me let me argue that that what
that then needs is a revolution in the
Academy that an Academy is exactly the
sort of place where those kind of
thoughts should occur but an academy
divided along narrow disciplinary lines
the Academy with a disdain for
multidisciplinary work is not the place
where it will occur now what the Academy
needs is an intellectual revolution in
the way we think about means and ends
and about the very purpose of innovation
itself and if we're going to answer the
questions of Donnell Kennedy then the
Academy itself has to be changed along
some of these actual dimensions the
circumstances then - in order to do this
not only make will make evaluation of
policy and ethical context actually
easier if it's actually done but also
provide a lot of potential benefits now
I we could think of many of the many of
the ways in which this can actually be
done I'm gonna argue that one of the
things that has to happen in in
academies like this is that they have to
strategically reposition themselves and
one of the repositioning is going to
occur through a redefinition of what we
actually mean by engineering the field
of engineering I argue is changing very
rapidly now um you heard some of the of
what the wolf had to actually say the
notion of of the complexity of the
systems we have meaning we have to
develop new kinds of engineering ethics
given that given that system of product
complexity are actually increased
increasing at an accelerating rate as
are the complexities of operating in a
global context where technical natural
social systems are increasing
interacting then what we need to do is
develop new kinds of leaders I'm going
to argue those leaders are will be
engineering system professionals who
consider the technological components of
what they do as part of a larger
engineering system paradigm and who
utilized different approaches in that
based upon a narrow disciplinary
engineering science paradigm and these
engineering system professionals should
consider the context in which the system
operates as a design variable as opposed
to a constraint
thus they'll be concerned with the
design of the organization has to
manufacture a system a product as well
as the regulations and public policies
governing its use in disposition
marketing the relationship with
suppliers distributors and other
participants in the value chain now as
an example of the broadened perspective
of this I think it's extremely
instructive to look at the changes that
have occurred in automotive design and
manufacture of automobiles the owner
automobile was once considered to be a
technologically mature product where I I
will remember there was a time even a
few years ago where some of the car
companies actually had trouble getting
MIT graduates to go to some of them
because they were considered to there
was nothing new that was actually
happening there once considered a
technologically mature product is now
influenced by new technology including
at the level of technologies lightweight
materials smart electronic components
alternate propulsion systems but in
addition to that there are other things
that affect the automobile the
globalization of the automobile industry
has shifted locations of both design and
manufacturing facilities from a national
to international context concerns such
as quality human resource management
time to market have motivated
fundamental changes in automotive
product development manufacturing and
supply chain design new approaches such
as just-in-time inventory control
integrated product development teams
lean production techniques have reshaped
companies automotive production
processes while social concerns such as
air pollution materials recycling global
warming and safety have had a major
impact on auto design and production
furthermore design and manufacturing are
any part of the system now government
policies determine the role of
automobiles in providing personal
mobility ensuring automotive safety and
impacting the environment and urban
development the development of effective
policies to deal with this system we
call the automobile cannot be based
solely on technical expertise but
require instead and understanding in
addition to technical expertise
understanding of institutions economics
human behavioral responses and non
technical considerations so the leaders
that are necessary to do that I'm going
to argue that these leaders have to
develop this interdisciplinary approach
of which the automobile is is an example
of these so these leaders will then
consider the context in which systems
are initiated designed manufactured
constructed implemented and maintained
the context is undergoing some
significant change as a result of
globalization the information revolution
and emerging social concerns for example
sustainability now I have to quote here
from president vas because I think he
said it very well he says this
perspective is reflected in president
West's comments in the president's
report humankind's advances will depend
increasingly on new integrative
approaches to complex systems problems
and structures design synthesis and
synergy across traditional disciplinary
boundaries will be essential elements of
both education research so in closing
I'm going to argue that the big issues
in society is cultural divide that is
created and perpetuated by our current
educational system and the accelerating
role pace of technological change in
society demands a change in the Academy
and it demands a new kind of societal
leader where I will argue cannot flow
from a new vision for engineering so at
this point you need to quote
my colleague dr. Larry Lyndon and he
says what the Academy must do is seek to
produce societal leaders who are one
skilled intellectually in dealing with
the many crucial technological
dimensions of our society to have the
practical results orientation
characteristic of engineering
professionals three have the courage
based on early experience to take on the
most difficult systems problems and for
the leadership skills to bring others
forward as they themselves move forward
these will be leaders bridging the gap
between technology and policy I think
part of the challenge facing OSTP as
well as you as well as the Academy is
how to help the academy re-engineer
itself to produce these kind of leaders
to deal with these kind of complex
systems in so doing I think it will help
ameliorate the societal responses to the
technologically driven changes if
anything you're only going to increase
and not doing that the status quo will
prevail and we will continue this
oscillation between techno optimism
techno pessimism and reactive policies
which sometimes occur as a result of
that so let me finish my comments here
we have a few minutes for a couple of
yes yeah I think after having listened
to all the species now something that is
missing nobody has ever thought about
how are the students admitted into the
universities and how are the engineers
trained because the universe is only
trained engineers who get jobs not
necessarily to know what they are going
to do out there but to train people who
are going to get the Bell job and they
market them so much well that they have
become scientists with yet knowledge not
what I'm taking taken well let me I
didn't completely understand thrust of
your question but I think it is the case
I'm arguing that one of the things that
needs to happen in engineering education
is that engineers need to be trained to
some set of Engineers they need to be
trained to become these kind of leaders
now having said that I think also
there's a need for that there's a need
could be a continued need to train
engineers as disciplinary people you
know who will go out and engineer the
next product well as long as there are
also people who will help understand how
those products are actually integrated
into society which can also be the role
of Engineers as long as long as it's
done properly in the educational system
we have one more question or comment
yes you thought you focused mainly on
the role of engineer how technology and
policy can reach out to engineering and
I was just willing if you could comment
some more - on how perhaps scientific
well science majors in particular could
be how that can be integrated as well
instead of just engineers that's that's
an interesting question I think that
it's important for some set some subset
of scientists to think clearly about the
implications of the science that they do
I'm not sure I believe it's important
for all scientists to be trained you
know this way because I think it's
important that scientists continue to be
trained to do fundamental science but
there needs to be enough of a leavening
in the science community so this doesn't
mean everybody just means it needs
enough of a leavening in the science
community so so that the the questions
that president Shapiro raised can be can
be raised with by scientists themselves
that is you know is it the case that we
should always go down this path given
that we have the potential to go down
this path I think it I think it's a not
a good thing for the society if it's the
case that you have this divide where a
scientist engineers just pursue one set
of paths which is a technocratic path
and you have other people humanists who
haven't have a have another set of ways
of looking at things and and bringing
that into it and and you end up getting
this kind of oscillation and divide I
think that some subset of scientists
should be thinking about these kind of
broader let's call it system and
societal issues so I wouldn't do it for
all scientists III I'm much more
inclined to say since since engineers
are in the business of building creating
things which which presumably help
society right I I would be much more
argue much more strongly that you need
to do this with a lot more engineers
than you need to do this with scientists
and that's my over right now
after which Danvers will share a session
with the defense technology and
biotechnology information technology
looks at issues and science and
technology policy current topics before
we get into the presentations I just
wanted to say a few words several people
have come up to me and asked me what is
the engineering systems division which
is one of the sponsors of this program
and Granger alluded to it and then
Hastings talked about the philosophy
behind the creation of ESD and one of
the principal programs of the division
the technology and policy program and
let me just take a few minutes and try
and answer that question because this is
a new unit at MIT which was set up two
years ago and many of us talk about
government bureaucracy and I suppose the
only organizations more bureaucratic
than government of universities and so
the engineering systems division I think
was is the first new institutional unit
in school of engineering at MIT in about
25 years
so it is significant from that point of
view it is an interdisciplinary unit
with faculty from management engineering
and Social Sciences all the faculty in
ESD of which we have 30 have dual
appointments so they have a half of
their appointment in the division and a
half of their appointment in one of the
departments in engineering or in the
Sloan School of Management we have eight
faculty from the Sloan School of
Management or one of the social science
departments so what it does is it
creates an institutional home which
we've never had for faculty who are
interested in a range of broader issues
beyond engineering science and the
charter of the division is to broaden
engineering education and broaden
engineering practice it's to look at how
one develops large-scale complex systems
be their transportation systems or
communication systems or energy systems
recognizing the technology is a
significant portion of the creation we
should have technical people in
leadership roles but if they're going to
be in leadership roles they have to
understand more than simply the
technology so in a sense it's going the
next step beyond what were very
successful programs created over the
last 20 years at MIT of which TPP is
certainly one others that you may be
familiar with our leaders for
manufacturing program system design and
management these are programs that focus
on professional practice and the broader
aspects of engineering and we're very
very pleased to be one of the principal
sponsors of this as kind of the new kids
in town and if any of you are interested
in finding out more about ESD just come
up and speak to me and we'll be
delighted to send you some information
well let me turn to the session this
afternoon
we have four presentations and during
the morning session we got the sense of
the minute-to-minute activities in in
Washington and the reactive nature of
the policy-making process and we are
seeing it in living action in that one
of our speakers fortunately only one had
a crisis today and was unfortunately
unable to attend but we're very pleased
that we have dr. Charles Holland who's a
director of Information Systems in the
DoD office
overseeing Science and Technology who
has at the last minute agreed to come up
and and speak to us today
he has PhD in Applied Mathematics from
Brown University early career in
academia and he's had 20 years of
government research management
experience in DoD and I'll go through
the presentations he will speak on
defense technology our second speaker is
dr. Philip shop
professor shop joined the MIT faculty in
1974 as an associate professor in the
department of biology and the center for
cancer research he was promoted to a
full professor in 1979 he served as
director of the center for cancer
research from 85 until 91 when he became
head of the biology department making
that an absolutely world-class
department in 1992 he was named the
Salvador Luria professor of biology and
in 1993
professor sharp shared the Nobel Prize
in Physiology or medicine for work that
fundamentally changed scientists
understanding of the structure of genes
he and dr. Richard Roberts of New
England Biolabs was awarded the prize
for their independent discovery that
some of the genes of higher organisms
are split or present in distinct
segments along the DNA molecule in 1999
in recognition of his world-renowned
research in his service to the MIT
community and nation
professor sharp was named Institute
professor the highest honor awarded by
the faculty and administration at MIT
and of a faculty of close to a thousand
I think there was something like 13
Institute professors so it really is a
very very distinguished title at this
institution phil is a graduate of Union
College he received his PhD in chemistry
from the University of Illinois at
Urbana and in addition to the Nobel
Prize
she has received numerous awards and
honors including the Albert Lasker basic
medical research award 1988 honorary
doctorates of science from five
universities and the James R Killian
faculty achievement award from MIT again
that's one of our highest honors dr.
David Clarke is our third speaker and he
is going to speak on the internet
communications and information
technology David Clarke is a senior
research scientist at the MIT laboratory
for computer science since the mid 70s
dr. Clarke has been leading the
development of the internet from 1981 to
1989 he acted as chief protocol
architect
in this development and he chaired the
internet Activities Board recent
activities include extensions to the
Internet to support real-time traffic
explicit allocation of service pricing
and related economic issues and policy
issues surrounding local loop employment
new activities focus on the architecture
of the Internet in the post PC era dr.
Clarke is chairman of the computer
science and telecommunications board of
the National Research Council and our
final speaker is Professor Ronald Prynne
professor Prynne is the tepco professor
atmospheric science and he's head of our
department of Earth atmospheric and
Planetary Science professor Prinze
research interests incorporate the
chemistry dynamics and physics of the
atmosphere the earth and other planets
and the chemical evolution of
atmospheres and MIT he directs the
center for global science change and
co-directs the joint program on the
science and policy of global change let
me just mention for a moment since I
don't think Ron will get into it and
it's talk a little bit about that
program because I think it's very
relevant in terms of our discussion
today
that one of the roles that an
institution like MIT can play and we've
heard this a number of times today is to
bring objectivity to a set of complex
issues where we can look at data we can
do analysis we can look at a variety of
alternatives and what their impacts are
but in many ways the forms of
communication have changed and if all we
did was to publish scholarly papers it's
not clear how many people would really
read those particularly industry
executives and government officials and
those are the people who we really want
to be aware of the objective analysis so
what we have tended to do in this
program which brings together a group of
scientists and economists and
policymakers is to serve as an honest
broker or a facilitator where on the
basis of once or twice a year a group of
people from around the world in industry
and government and other stakeholders
get together with the researchers with
Ron and his group and they present their
research results and there's a
discussion and so it's much more of a
dialogue in which the university really
is taking on an important role to
hopefully influence policy making but
not we're not proposing the policies
we're simply providing the analysis to
this group for a discussion well Ron
leads the advanced global atmospheric
gases experiment in which the rates of
increase of the concentrations of the
trace gases involved in greenhouse
effect and ozone depletion have been
measured continuously over the global
environment since 1978
he's pioneering the use of inverse
methods which use such measurements to
determine trace gas emissions and
understand atmospheric chemical
processes
dr. Prynne is a fellow of the American
Geophysical Union a 1981 recipient of
the AG use but sure I'll get this right
McIlwain
metal and the 84 for a nadeska Memorial
Lecture of the USSR Academy of Sciences
he served this chair for atmospheric and
hydrosphere
sciences the American Association for
the Advancement of science integral
inaugural chair of the International
global atmospheric chemistry project and
chaired the National Research Council
Committee on Earth Sciences and we have
I am told a special treat at the end of
Rods presentation which will find out
more about so let me turn this now over
to our first speaker good afternoon it's
a pleasure to be here when I first found
out about this conference several months
ago I was very interested in attending
this conference because over the last 20
years or so I've been involved in a
series of policy issues I did leave out
one part of my biography that I actually
worked at the office of Technology
Assessment under Jack Gibbons and
produced a report on world petroleum
availability that you know almost
succeeded in getting the organization
eliminated in 1980 since it it got
published during the Reagan election
when campaign win and while we thought
we were had a just a technical
assessment there were some people who
thought there were political overtones
in the report I didn't get the
organization eliminated but uh I guess
survived for another 25 years or so
before her 20 years or so before
unfortunately it's in a state of
inactivity I guess it's a good way of
putting it
but since then I've also been involved
in a series of issues related to sort of
high performance computing information
assurance that involve the important
interactions with OSTP and trying to
convey
you know what the Defense Department can
really do in certain activities that are
sort of both domestic and international
well but my boss this morning she found
out that she had to be somewhere this
afternoon and she gave me a phone call
and said could I please give this talk
for her
so I agreed to do so so the government
can move fast you know at least I can so
there's a little bit of a caution here
this is sort of her talk but you know
whenever I stray a little bit from what
appears to be standard remarks it's
probably my remarks and I'm the guilty
culprit if you want to refer back to
anyone what's happening of course then
in the Defense Department right now is
like every other agency we're going
through a transition from the political
appointees at the top of the previous
administration to the replacements in
this administration we have a new
Secretary of Defense we have a new
Undersecretary of Defense and then if we
move down the chain of command to
Science and Technology we have Pete
Aldrich who went up for congressional
hearings last week who's in charge of
acquisition technology and logistics
it's Mike yes he'll probably be
confirmed this week and then we'll get
down to the director of defense research
and engineering position which is the
first major foot position that oversees
Science and Technology I happen to be a
career political I mean I happen to be a
career employee in the federal
government okay a little bit about the
importance of Science and Technology to
the Department of Defense our job is to
make sure that we develop superior and
work in affordable technology that give
our soldiers were fighting and war
winning capabilities and we've been
pretty successful at that over the last
20 years and I'll tell you a little bit
about how we go about that business if
you look at some of the advances that we
rely upon today to execute the missions
that we've been successful in such as
stealth night-vision Global Positioning
Systems phased array radars on Aegis
lasers adaptive optics in the upper
right hand corner of that slide you see
a picture of the projected ABL system
for example that comes out of
high-energy lasers these are these are
very important capabilities for the
Department of Defense
they've taken 20 years
so years to mature and they were they
require sort of a you know a sustained
investment in science and technology if
you think about the ABL program for
example the first work on the chemical
oxygen iodine laser was in the early 70s
so we've actually got a good portfolio
of programs and techniques for the
current environment but in fact the
current environment is changing and
that's part of the challenges that we
face the challenges that the Defense
Department faces is and I would say at
least three dimensions and one dimension
is the fact that we're doing something
other than just fighting one major
threats the former Soviet threat
we're fighting a Syria we were involved
in a series of sort of activities that
range from sort of peacekeeping to a
manatorian the second challenge that we
face is that we now have adversaries who
can attack us an asymmetric ways we're
very concerned about sort of chem bio
warfare information assurance and these
the challenge for us and of course in
the Defense Department is not only to
help us when the activities that were
involved in but we sort of have to
understand what role were expected to
play in homeland defence also the third
challenge for us or the third the third
dimension is the globalization of
Technology with the web and everything
people are getting access to technology
as quickly as is we're getting access to
it in most areas and how do we quickly
get it in systems much faster than our
adversaries so technology is both a
benefit and sort of a potential problem
for us but our belief is we just got to
keep running faster so how do we run
faster well we run faster with dollars
and we spent it in Porter in areas if
you look at the roughly 300 billion
dollar defense budget there's an RTT
annie line which everybody talks about
which is 41 billion but it's really the
science of technology dollars down there
but the roughly nine billion dollars
that we use to generate the ideas that
are going to produce the future forces
that we have for the for the military
departments and there's a classification
that goes from six one two six three
that number is nine billion this year
we're reasonably optimistic so now you
can quote me
it's not my boss's statement that I
think that number will be up next year
so a couple of slides quickly to try and
set the stage for the Defense Department
there are agencies that have money and
then they give them the money to people
within the Defense Department there's
the army the Navy the Air Force
there's the Defense Advanced Research
Projects Agency there's the office of
the Secretary of Defense which I report
to and other agencies such as bimbo and
d'etre and what you see here is a
color-coded chart that goes from six one
two six three and this is how the
distribution of funds start each of
these activities were on sort of you
know competitive programs to attack
there are title ten responsibilities and
we also do joint planning make sure we
have an integrated program and this
money then from six one two six three
goes out to academia the government labs
into industry and as you might expect
and six one universities are there major
recipients of that funding as you move
to six to the university still get a
reasonable amount of money but it's sort
of make a split between the government
labs and industry as being the dominant
funder and then if you get closer to
more applied programs it goes up the
contribution to industry increases a
little bit about the perspective of that
money if you really look at that for the
Defense Department as a whole that money
in science and technology you saw for
the army the Navy and the Air Force
that's roughly two percent of the
service budgets and we like to think of
it in this respect what do you get for
that two percent well we do two things
we do three things we we fight today or
we operate today we're trying to procure
new systems for the next force so f-22
jsf that are only lists the politically
correct procurements underway I guess
right now and those are the ones here
but the S&T is really about the force
after next it's a small amount of money
only being
2% of the service budgets therefore it's
important that we spend every dollar
wisely and we always need to keep
reminding those people who have problems
over here this is a small amount of
money we can't really pay the bills in
case they're increased operations we
can't we can't pay the bills in case
their cost overruns on procurements well
how have we been doing over history well
not a slide I wanted to show but I think
we're doing ok and oh one so we've
leveled off but I think the o2 number is
going to go up what you see in the
difference between the appropriated and
the President's budget request is that
Congress always gives us a little bit
extra a lot of times that's in programs
that we really want sometimes it's well
I think we'd rather have a little bit
more flexibility in the dollars ok one
last slide about budgets we always put
this slide up it's to me this is a
slightly depressing budget for one
service which shows you that 12 years
ago and in the late 80s the Air Force
was the leading service and investing in
science and technology and as you can
see now it's its third so what are the
challenges that face us and and what are
we trying to do about it we're a big
believer in basic research we're always
worried about the generation of new
ideas especially within this area for
which we seem to have some supremacy and
we really need to make sure that we're
generating new talent I mean we have the
same concerns that dr. Kowal has and we
have strong educational programs and
support for postdocs but we need to keep
that pipeline pipeline full we're
responding to some really hard problems
today so as you think about attacking
things from the more applied side I
would say the three challenges for us
today are that are significant or chem
biological defense information assurance
how do you protect your networks
ensure that the commercial software that
you buy from somebody really is going to
work as intended and as we've sort of
won the ability in certain areas to be
able to attack our adversaries what
they've done is they've gone really
underground on us they've gone a lot of
facilities we'd like to get out from
from Kim bio to other they're either
deep underground or they're in tunnels
and so we have a real challenge about
trying to figure out how to find those
targets characterize those targets and
come up with mechanisms for attacking
those targets and there's a lot of
Science and Technology involved it in in
that arena we're pursuing some
revolutionary capabilities just list
three here we're very interested in
high-energy lasers for the abl and other
activities perhaps instead of electric
drive that should say electric electric
technologies in general for both
unmanned vehicles as well as sort of
other high power applications and we
really think the time is right to sort
of pursue robotics both in the air at
the ground and the sea in that regard I
would like to say that you know the Army
for example didn't make it to Kosovo and
so there were they were advised that you
know you really are supposed to show up
in the first 30 60 90 days and so the
Army is undergoing a major
transformation have a series of sort of
contracts grants and contracts under how
do we become lighter how do we actually
get somewhere in time and so I think
you're going to say a big change in the
way the army is planning to fight in the
future and then we have not everything
is revolutionary you really got to
sustain certain areas high-performance
computing computing architectures some
areas that in fact I think we've let
fall below the critical mass level and I
should say that an additional technical
issues there's a range of non-technical
issues sometimes you get excited about
the fact that budgets going up one year
but you can't ever let your guard down
because it might go back down the next
year we're producing a lot of technology
what's that our challenges as I said
earlier is getting it into fielded
systems and we have a big problem with
the SMT work
for us and for us that's academia as
well as the government laughs you know
how do we generate people how do we hire
people so we have a lot of challenges
but I would like to conclude by saying
science and technology is very critical
for the Department of Defense we take
these challenges seriously because it's
very important for us
thank you have some do we have some
questions yes
[Music]
you know there are a lot of programs
that I don't know about in those
programs that are so highly classified I
wouldn't know if we lost it or not so
all right I don't know I did you know I
the only thing you Mike I used to sort
of have these discussions with with
people in the airforce and of course it
was
well maybe the Air Force doesn't need so
much in S&T because we're really out
doing it all in the black so that's
another it another aspect of that
question I don't really think they are
but I don't know right and the thing is
the you know with classification there's
there's some good things about
classification there's some bad things
about classification yes
someone's realistic estimate of a
credible threat what was it what was the
threat scenario used in this review or
can you talk about that yet you know I'm
not part of the ante Marshall review I
like you I'm still waiting to hear
exactly the outcome of that so it's not
known within the the do even OSD what's
going on I would say it's I say I would
only answer that I personally do not
know that okay you have any idea when
that's I mean Andy Marshall works in the
office of Secretary of Defense so so
it's no with an OSD at the highest
levels but I've just not party to that
we'll take one final question Jeanne
budget national missile defense come out
of your future S&T or whether it has to
be an add-on you mean do I think it's
gonna come out of that nine billion if
you're asking me okay for an unofficial
statement I don't think the S&T the
current S&T budget is gonna pay for nmd
okay thank you very much thank you it's
been an enjoyable day and I congratulate
the OSTP on its 25th anniversary
my relationship with OSTP is that I had
the pleasure of serving on PCAST under
Jack Gibbons for a number of years and
it taught me that public policy is a
slow process it takes years sometimes
and being there at the right time to say
the right word at the right place is key
to the whole process we heard today a
number of issues
that I had listed on my comment to raise
as issues that science advisor and OSTP
might address in the future things like
stem cells and cloning and human
genetics and genetic engineering all
these are very significant issues that
has been mentioned throughout today they
all directly address the issue of what
it means in some ways to be human we are
beginning to understand more and more
about the human creature and to
understand how it evolved and how it
functions and these this information is
very new challenges a lot of people's
thoughts and will always be a very
complicated political issue but as we
work through that I want to hark back to
the beginning of biotechnology for a few
moments and remind you of where the
science came from and how it was
introduced obviously
the origins of biotechnology really
began in 53 with Watson and Crick
discovering the structure of DNA and the
birth of the discipline of molecular
biology and then over the intervening
years from 53 to the mid 70s
universities such as MIT and Harvard and
many others made large investments in
the liquid or biology primarily because
it was an intellectually challenging and
exciting new frontier in science there
was very little or almost no discussion
of the potential applications of this
technology to either societal problems
in pharmaceuticals or in any other
aspect and then in mid seventies there
was this discovery of recombinant DNA
the ability to genetically engineered
DNA joined DNA together and the
scientific community stepped back at
that moment in the mid 70s and said
let's debate this issue and there was a
large and very widespread public debate
and in fact the year ago I had the
pleasure of going out to celebrate the
25th anniversary of Silla mar where a
group of scientists met and debated
after
dorium a moratorium respected around the
world I should note doing recombinant D
DNA debated the introduction of this
technology and how this introduction
should be regulated as it's introduced
into society and I want to remind you of
what those regulations were they were
guidelines they were guidelines left at
the level of NIH and those guidelines
were meant to evolve as the technology
evolved in through this very public
process we gained the confidence both of
the country and of the city of Cambridge
ultimately to begin this research and
this was painful believe me this was
painful for a young scientist such as
myself who just arrived at MIT who
wanted nothing more than to be left
alone in a laboratory to exploit this
wonderful technology for which I could
explore the essence of what a human cell
was like but he was out of that public
debate and out of that public response
that we gained the confidence of the
country to move forward and we have
embraced genetic engineering and
recombinant DNA in this country as no
other country has and I believe it was
this public process that achieved it
now we're setting at a second revolution
a revolution that I would harken back to
being as great as the recombinant DNA
revolution and that revolution is being
brought by the human genome sequence and
the advent of large massive sequencing
and this information is wedding in the
most simplistic way biology and
computation and informational sciences
and we are collecting massive amounts of
information that we can then use as we
come to each experiment and try to
understand how biological systems both
function in multi gene analysis systems
biology as well as how they arrive in
rows in evolution and this is a
wonderful advance brought forth by
public funding and in the very public
sector and I want to say one thing about
this science it needs to continue
after we sequence a human with this
technology we're just beginning we
should need the sequence the mouse and
that's ongoing we need to sequence the
rat but we need the sequence about all
organisms we need the sequences plant we
need the sequence that flower we need
the sequence every agricultural crop we
need to sequence mosquitoes in Brazil we
need the sequence and because we've
learned that obtaining the sequence of a
wide variety of organisms and comparing
them is the most direct and powerful and
cost-efficient way of understanding how
biological systems function and how they
arose in evolution now the sequence
itself of the human genome is not even
close to being the end of this science
of studying man if you look at the
initial publications which propose
35,000 genes I can tell you from
detailed analysis of what a gene is like
we don't know how many genes are in the
human genome 35,000 is a good guess but
it could be something depending on how
you define a gene as much larger or it
even could be more simple if you're
looking at specific functions so and if
we look at those 35,000 genes we only
know the function we don't know the
function at all of 42 percent of them of
the other 58 percent we know the general
function but not the specific function
for most of them so we know the specific
function of only about 10% 15% I would
say of the human genome so there's a
great deal of science to be done and it
will be the basis of increasing rate of
discovery which will drive biomedical
science and biotechnology to create new
and more sophisticated drugs and
therapies and treatments over the next
decades and in society is going to look
at that technology and have to come to
grips with the issue of how we deal with
the cost of medical care cost of medical
care or the total fraction of cost is
approximately 15 to 20 percent of the
gross national product this new
technology is going to drive it there's
going to be change to pharmaceuticals
and less may be in hospital
nation and changes in the whole process
and that in essence is going to be part
of a political process that the country
is going to have to decide how its going
to do it however new technology is
coming in the new technology will drive
this change and that is mostly
biomedical science now behind this human
genome sequence is human genetics and it
will be the most direct and immediate
impact of having the sequence we will
have rapid advances in human genetics to
both diagnose and then predict the
treatment of diseases but as you well
know and has been mentioned several
times the application and distribution
of humans genetic information across
society is a major issue dealing with
genetic privacy informed content in
Scent in terms of attaining the genetic
material of individuals disclosure of
genetic information job discrimination
and insurance coverage all these issues
are very important have to be dealt with
in a political and societal means and we
heard today from Herald and others about
this as policy issues I only want to
raise one little sector of this it's how
you draft those regulations is going to
impact on how this science advances so
you have to remember as you draft this
right these regulations that the science
is going to change the power of science
changes much more rapidly than you
anticipate what is one issue today is
another issue tomorrow and if you have
to go to Congress to change role laws or
rules it's a very slow process so when
possible that should be incremental in
any way that you can make it now as
we've heard today and I just want to
reiterate the statement being a
biologist it has been a fantastic vote
of confidence in my science in the
doubling of the NIH budget but I have to
echo the words that others have said as
to how important it is for biological
science that research
in math physics chemistry and
engineering is also increase one of the
major limitations now in biotechnology
is actually production of these very
large by o'the complicated biological
molecules fermentation tanks facilities
that cost hundreds of million dollars to
put together it is actually limiting for
some therapeutics now to produce them
with with technology and it is engineers
and process scientists who know how to
do this and are needed in that
technology in the area of imaging and
the human brain if I could image
activity in the human brain at the level
of a single cell in the time resolution
of a millisecond I could give you
fundamental advances in how the human
brain processes information that I am
certain will lead to treatment and
control of diseases that we can't treat
now on are tragic in terms of the
humanity of specific people and that
advance is directly dependent upon
engineering physics and chemistry
because that's where the science has to
come from
that'll make ultimately that type of
advance I want to say one thing about
stem cells which have been mentioned
here many times before and that is that
stem cell research is one of the more
exciting frontiers developing in human
physiology I have seen publications of
people who have been able to use stem
cells to regenerate liver I've seen
publications of stem cells regenerating
muscle I've seen publications of stem
cells taken from humans put into Mouse
and regenerating in Mouse what looks
like neurons now you may ask why would
the scientist put a stem cell of a human
into a mouse and generate neurons are
they asking for trouble no but what we
could do by that method if it turns out
that these are really truly functional
neurons is to understand the nature of
genetic diseases in men by studying the
physiology
of them in a complex model system where
we can look at directly the function of
s cell in a warring complicated
physiological system so I can't tell you
where stem cells are going to lead in
the potential understanding and
treatment of human disease but I do know
it's an important area of science
it's a area in which we need to deal
with the issues of Public Policy and how
stem cells are obtained there are
multiple sources of sim cells not all of
them are equivalent and we need the
access to stem cells from early
embryonic tissue or eggs to actually
fully explore this area of science last
I want to mention the International
nature of science and health we have
seen in the press daily now the debate
of the control of AIDS in South Africa
and in the third world and clearly
health and health policy in the third
world influences us the world is a small
place with very rapid travel between
different places and how HIV is
controlled in the third world impacts on
us not only in the context of the virus
moving from one location to the other
but in the context of drug-resistant
variants arising that will quickly
bypass the therapeutics that we have so
developing an understanding and the
International control of disease is an
important issue for this country and for
the health of the citizens in this
country and I only have to remember at
the last summer when my home in Newton
was sprayed because someone found a crow
that was dead with West Nile virus in it
and in fact all of Cambridge was sprayed
several times by helicopter because of a
West Nile virus being found in virus in
in crows that were dead in this part of
the country now I don't know if we're
going to have West now reappear this
summer it is possible but in essence
this is a small world and we need to
deal with
diseases in an international way and I
went in with one statement about this
ultimate control of HIV in the world is
going to depend on vaccines vaccines are
underdeveloped it should shortly be
hopefully possible to develop a vaccine
against HIV and as soon as we have a
vaccine against HIV which will have to
be developed in some way tested in
third-world as well as the US we're
going to have to have a policy of how to
distribute that vaccine in the third
world and I expect that to be a major
issue if we are so lucky as to be able
to develop one in the next four years
thank you Thanks fell questions yes
one big difference between Asilomar now
is the emergence of the biotech industry
and you're proposing a model of
regulation which is built on voluntary
compliance or at the most restrictions
on what fit people get federal funds -
as in stem cells and cloning and I
wonder whether the community of
scientists is strong enough to to bring
the biotech industry into some community
standards in the present yura is this
mode of regulation really relevant for
today given the given the the
differences between now and the
beginning of the of the period I want to
make two statements maybe I was not
clear I one of the take-home messages
from my comments about recombinant DNA
and the introduction of it is that it is
healthy for wide public debate
so in GMO organisms what we missed in
the last 15 years is a wide public
debate of how those organisms were used
so I think the public debate is the only
way to reach consensus second I'll say
for the biotech and the pharmaceutical
industry there is nothing that shakes
one of the executives and those
industries as much as the prospect of
litigation so if there is a public
policy that says we do not do X I can
almost guarantee you that in the private
sector related to that X will not be
done because of this issue so in the big
in the pharmaceutical industries that
depend upon obvious leads societal
support through the stock market and
other means I cannot say what the
response would be and other private
organizations that might be much smaller
and more entrepreneurial but I don't
believe in in large pharmaceuticals if
there was a public policy that was
uniformly recommended that they would
bridge that
the graviton sorry
you see the future of proteomics being
perhaps more promising than genomics I'm
so flushed with excitement about
genomics right now and trying to bring
that to fruition
I wouldn't want to answer the question
proteomics is a very important
technology it is a an area of science
that doesn't have a simple one answer
like genomics there's only one genome
you got two sequences a genome you know
what the sequence of the genome is
proteomics is a much more open-ended
subject much more biological and in many
ways much more interesting and profound
because of that but how it will impact
on society through the development and
treatment of disease understanding
diagnosis and treatment disease is
before us if biotechnology is
essentially sort of the mix between
engineering and medicine what was being
discussed before in terms of engineering
ethics and its relation to medicine when
it comes to something like the an HIV
vaccine in context of let's say a
trillion dollar tax cut is it what do
you think the what do you think that
debate will look like in terms of
current pharmaceutical policy and
general societal feeling towards helping
people in the third world with diseases
we know how to cure already I don't
think a lot of issues in there but I'll
take one biotechnology and a large
number of pharmaceutical companies are
making large investments in how to
develop an HIV vaccine and that's
wonderful
I would love to have and the society
needs an HIV vaccine at the time and
making the decision as to how this
vaccine if we are so successful as there
was chief one is going to be made
available in the third world you can't
leave that on the shoulders of the
pharmaceutical industry that's going to
have to be a participation by a broader
society who is also going to invest in
some ways in doing that because it's
just something that a subset
of the whole sector of society would not
be able to do it's a broader question
and we're going to have to develop a
national consensus that that's important
for national health good afternoon
so it's getting late in the day and I
have 15 minutes to say something new and
interesting about the internet which is
a bit of a challenge since I think all
known pundits have tried to do exactly
the same thing sort of a worn out topic
Bob try I note that the OSTP and the
Internet are about the same age if you
want to make the Internet look older you
can tack the ARPANET ears onto the
beginning but basically what I call real
Internet data started flowing sometime
around the mid 1970s and so that's only
about 25 years sir rather astonishing
amount of stuff that's happened it
doesn't seem that long ago although from
a personal perspective I got my PhD in
1973 so I guess it's been my whole
career sort of time flies when you're
having fun kind of a situation
we spent the the 70s basically just
getting the basic structure right I like
to remind people how little we knew in
the 1970s we didn't even have the
experience back then or the confidence
to to believe we could write down a
specification such that if two people
then went off and wrote some code based
on that specification that the resulting
systems would talk to each other if
unless you can do that you can't build
an open system and there was a lot of
doubt that we could actually build it
today it seems sort of obvious but in
fact it wasn't until it was proved and
that was sort of the the 1970s of the
Internet era so what happened in the
1980s was we dealt with the problem of
getting big and the bill talked about
well there's the classic engineer first
just specify and then you design and you
build and you test well the Internet
ain't that the Internet's the classic
example of a system that was hardly ever
designed and will never get done
building it we've been doing remedial
engineering of a sort that sometimes
we're proud of and sometimes we hide for
about 20
for years what happened in the 1980s is
people figured out some of the original
design decisions wouldn't scale for
example in the beginning we named
computers in a very simple way they had
names like MIT 1 MIT to MIT 3 that was
it ok you know it doesn't scale to say a
hundred million computers so so computer
scientists applied the only technology
they have to solve this problem which is
hierarchy and that's what gave us the
domain name system so now you get names
like you know
mumble mumble dot LCS mit.edu we had to
do the same thing with the addresses it
used to be we had a very simple address
structure we could name a huge number of
networks I 100 256 I think and some
we've actually realized that that was
wrong twice and we also had to change
the routing the way we send little
messages around the internet initially
every single machine in the Internet
knew about every other machine I said
well you know that's a few million
machines that's not going to work say
impose hierarchy right the other thing
we did in the 1980s is we we realized
that the management structure itself was
getting big and we had to organize that
when we started there were 12 people in
the room and we could do anything we
wanted because nobody cared and sometime
in the 80s there was a there was a
watershed meeting we held a meeting and
a hundred people came and we basically
said oh gosh unless we do something
we're going to die and so we did the
only good thing you know how to do we
created hierarchy we created a person in
charge in areas and subcommittees and
working groups and in fact that has
along with some more formal design
process he's done pretty well today the
internet meetings are still open anybody
can go to an engineering task force
meeting typical attendance would be
about 2,000 most people find it a little
overwhelming but you can come the other
thing that happened in the 80s in the
late 80s something happened that was
important to me personally I was asked
to be on a study committee of the
computer science and telecommunications
board which is part of the National
Academies down in Washington it was
actually one of the first studies that
the academies that the csdb released it
was called toward a national research
network and it was the encouragement to
the National Science Foundation to build
up the network that became the NSFNET
there was originally one built out of I
hate to remind people 56 kilobits
our national links in the beginning were
the speed you can get the day out of a
dial-up modem and that went to t1 which
is a megabit and a half and then it went
to ds3 and it was only in 1988 that the
advice to the NSF that this was a good
thing and they should keep doing it
came out of the came out of the the CSTB
I was also milestone for me because it
represented an opportunity to get
exposed to people not all of whom were
pure techies I met the board director a
woman named Marjorie Blumenthal who
basically beat me up and persuaded me it
was appropriate to talk to economists
and lawyers and social advocates and
policymakers and this was quite a
revelation to me I actually ended up
working on a series of internet studies
for the board those are interesting
check points how did we think about this
at various times in the distant past
that we can no longer remember like six
years ago so if the 80s were the decade
of getting big the 90s were the decade
of commercialization commercial Internet
service providers appeared as a new
industry player and they proposed to
start carrying Internet traffic as a
profit-making venture which in the
beginning is remarkable and astonishing
some people actually think they gonna
make money doing this that really sped
things up I like to remember that NSF
net was decommissioned in 1994 plus or
minus a year depending on how you think
about it that's sound like six or seven
years ago all of the commercial activity
the investment the internet bubble the
shattered stock prices all of this has
happened in something like seven years
which is really quite amazing so now the
question is what does the next decade
bring we've gone through the 70s and the
80s and the nights I don't know what do
you call the next decade the O's I don't
know what comes after commercialization
well the overused word is convergence I
would say collision what happened in the
80s and 90s this tremendous expansion
that we saw really occurred unimpeded
because it was happening in a vacuum
if you think about the World Wide Web
when it happened there wasn't a
pre-existing industry player that
supplied sort of proprietary web service
it was an empty space and the web just
blew into it the same for email
actually if you want to think about the
cycle of innovation the web is a
fascinating example the web at the time
when it was first proposed was not a new
idea if you chase back the general
vision of linked information you go back
at least a Vannevar bush and there were
prior attempts to do something like the
web but they fizzled they didn't launch
the timing wasn't right or they were too
proprietary or something happened but
when the LeWeb launched it launched
about as fast as anything we've seen I
mean maybe Napster launched faster but
then it didn't achieve orbit the first
working paper for the web was about 1990
Tim berners-lee wrote and he still has
it on his wall so that's almost you know
it's not quite 11 years from very first
concept to what we see today I find that
astonishing too but at the same time
it's an anomaly because as I say these
things happened in the vacuum as soon as
you say the words Internet telephony or
Internet music distribution or internet
radio you're launching into a space
occupied by an entrenched multi hundred
billion dollar industrial player and he
doesn't just roll over and die when you
touch him right at a minimum he thrashes
around a lot and even if he eventually
dies he does a lot of damage in the mean
time so it's interesting to ask can you
actually imagine a telephone company
dying I was interested that the recent
rumor that got loose that loosened was
about to file for bankruptcy caused its
price to drop from its current miserable
level of 9 to an even more miserable
level of 6 so there were people out
there who believed it and there was a
senior vice president of AT&T in 1995
who said to me you know the only problem
that AT&T has over the next 10 years is
to move from our current revenue model
to a new revenue model without
accidentally going out of business in
the next 10 years so they have three or
four more years to try it they've since
then torn themselves apart three times
or twice and of course the telephone
interview special because not only did
they have to deal with the internet but
they had to deal with this being you
know in position of competition on what
had been a monopoly and the whole sort
of aftershocks the divestiture so they
had two problems at once which is
probably more than most people can bear
but what happens when you run into a
pre-existing industry well some things
are obvious one is of course the growth
slows okay another thing that happens is
that across the boundary of the
collision you get slowed
fusion of insight so internet people got
a little more like Bell heads and Bell
heads got a little bit more like
Internet people
but the diffusion process was slow we
had cultural problems but the thing that
really was a bucket of cold water to the
Internet designers who of course had
grown up in what you might call the
Silicon Valley mentality is that some of
these industries came equipped with
something we hadn't seen before which is
a regulatory framework and people were
saying well you know if you're gonna
carry Internet telephone calls then you
should be regulated like a telephone
company that was an unthinkable thought
that was a heresy that was like we'd
entered a different world I guess it was
just that happened to be the one that
was centered in Washington DC and the
real horrifying insight was that this
was only the first of many collisions we
we said Internet telephony first and so
the telephone companies went um but
internet radio has its regulatory
context internet and music distribution
and what you might call some concerns
about intellectual property rights we
might discover we carried every single
one of those burdens at the same time if
the Internet can carry anything for some
value of anything then don't we have all
of these obligations aren't we
simultaneously a Content distributor and
a common carrier this is an alarming
thought and sometime in the 90s it came
into focus for me in a very clear way
which is the Revel is a revelation that
the techies were no longer in charge
they were simply going along for the
ride and I have to say that's when the
csdb where I had a chance to talk to
economists and businessmen and lawyers
got more interesting I I joke I spent 10
years learning how to talk to economists
and now I have to talk to lawyers trying
to talk to the FCC the first time was a
total disaster so what's going to happen
in the ooohs well an other thing is
we're going to go how to pay for the
internet I don't actually believe in
banner ads but if banner ads tanked then
what happens well if the revenue for the
web pages dries up then there aren't as
many web pages if there aren't in manys
web pages then maybe the consumer
experience gets boring and if the
consumer experience gets boring they
stop buying and the whole thing goes
back and crawls in a hole and it was all
a mistake
No
a little pessimistic but part of what I
did learn is that we don't have that we
don't know how to route money around the
internet very well we can't implement
all the value equations that people have
and somebody very cynically said you're
a bunch of damn techies you were good at
routing packets you're lousy at routing
money and I have to say back in 1975 or
even 85 it was hard to realize that the
internet was really about routing money
but you know okay wake up so here's the
third point about the O's what we're
really going to have to deal with in the
next decade is the extent to which
society has a say in how the internet
comes out in 1990 I don't know - there
was an interesting phenomenon which is
gore stood up and said I have a vision
of the national information
infrastructure and it was an interesting
moment for me he said that and there was
this saw at a feeding frenzy when
everybody came to Washington to get the
money and then he said the private
sector will build the NII and they all
went away again now there was actually
what sort of spontaneous creation of
various sort of standards bodies and
advocacy groups which having come into
existence in that moment immediately
said about preserving their own
existence but you know they faded into
the landscape we hardly think about them
anymore but what I learned is the
division is a dangerous thing especially
to the private sector the private sector
sort of explores the world by
experimenting in all directions and if
you survive you get to play again and a
vision tilts the playing field and what
happens if I tilt the playing field
against you well it's completely
unacceptable so a vision is a very
dangerous thing so what really happened
right then to a significant extent is
that we where we as some value the
government representing society or the
Internet leaders who suddenly realized
we no longer had a mandate to lead we
took her hands off the controls and the
internet sort of drifted now drifted I'm
sorry drifted is too passive a word wet
in all directions is it fast is it good
okay well how is it going to come out
over the next 10 years it's going to
take a lot of talking um and what
interests me you know my libertarian
friends say well I'm worried about the
government getting involved in the
internet that isn't particularly
worrying but we sort of know what the
government does what worries me is the
new industrial players we created look
think about the Internet service
provider for a minute you know you can
predict what the government is going to
do they're concerned with you know law
enforcement
Zoomer protection but what's the ISP
wants to do it wants to make money
having created a mist comes a
profit-making organization how's it
gonna make money well anyway you can
figure out that doesn't fall prey to say
antitrust and there's an interesting
structural problem the ISP sits in the
center of the net well what's in the
center of the net just packet forwarding
it's very primitive so that's a pretty
much a commodity business if you're in
the middle and you'd like to make money
what would you like to do you'd like to
get control of what people are doing
well the internet was supposed to be
transparent to carry any kind of packet
what happens when you get in the middle
and you start controlling what people
can do for example some ISPs do they
have rules they say you can't have a
server in your house you can't have a
game server or a web server or this kind
of server that if you want to have a
server you've got to pay me more you can
have a client in your house well to a
person who's familiar with sort of the
economics of value pricing that's just
trying to discover the internet
equivalent of the Saturday night stay
but - it's what classic internet
thinkers it's simply a moral wrong and
needs to be rectified we're gonna have
to sort this out and it's going to take
a lot of talking so what can we say
about the future well the first thing is
the results of commercialization are not
clear it's gonna work itself out in the
next decade I think it's gonna result no
doubt in calls to the government to
protect the Internet protect its virtue
you know protect the purity of the
end-to-end argument maybe it's a
argument that the internet should be
defined by the government and we're
going to have a rather fascinating
societal debate about who's in charge or
at least who gets to sit at the table
when the future of the Internet is
debated we're going to sort out the role
of the government and it's going to be a
new role because they're not in charge
nor are they completely stepping away
from the table I said I don't
necessarily believe that we're doing a
good job of convergence but when you
when you get these collisions between
sectors one of the things that
it happens is that boundaries blur and
you have to deal with that we sort of
have confidence that we know what a
phonecall is but what's an internet
telephone call
well is it a phone call if by definition
you cannot dial nine-one-one is it a
phone call if it doesn't ring now that's
a scary space we're talking about the
edge of definitions Engineers like to
stand in the middle of definition so you
say Oh build a bridge that holds up ten
thousand pounds well fine we said I'll
build a bridge that can hold up thirty
so I don't have to think about the edges
of the def no engineer asked to build a
bridge that holds up ten thousand pounds
would build a bridge that falls down at
ten thousand 100 who likes to stand at
the edge of a definition to say I'm over
the line yet am i over the haglöf he's
called the lawyer lawyers like the edges
of definitions right and judges why do
we call them a judgement they make a
judgement they definitely they like they
picked the job of standing on a slippery
slope right so all of a sudden we're
going to have lawyers telling us what is
and is not internet radio what is and is
not an Internet telephone call okay it's
really scary okay it's also reality now
the last observation I would make is
that we still have a lot of remedial
engineering to do in the internet and in
the 1980s the remedial engineering had
to do with getting big in the 90s the
remedial engineering had to do with the
fact that commercialization raised some
special problems in the O's the remedial
engineering will have to do with
addressing some serious social issues
and this brings me back to the space
that Dan Hastings was talking about
because I go to some of my colleagues
and I say here's a good hard technical
problem and they say that's just a
social issue I don't want to work on
that we have a cultural something broken
in our collective culture okay even a
hard technical problem that derives from
a social motivation as opposed to it
doesn't go fast enough we should stop
being a speed centered discipline
somehow seems less exciting credible
hard we have to get over that and of
course the other thing we have to do in
the O's is figure out how to pay for it
we have time for one quick question for
Dave okay you've left us speechless
the difficulty in translating scientific
research into a form that can be
understood by the public
so I'll for the focus moon is it on
there yes I'll focus my talk around
communication of the science but at the
same time take the opportunity to tell
you about where the science of global
warming stands at the present time now
there are variety of ways in which
people have tried to communicate global
warming and here's a recent example
which is useful I think that it probably
made people buy this particular issue of
Time magazine at least to find out what
was going on however you look at this
and you decide you know it's a frying
pan with an egg in it and some people
may get deeply worried about that that
we're frying the earth which is clearly
a very wrong depiction of what global
warming is about at the same time if you
like fried eggs you might conclude the
global warming is good so that's an
attempt and maybe it has some success
another way to do it which I've used
many times is to use simple cartoons and
this is an example of one of them
schematic of the greenhouse issue and
this can be useful I use this to make
the point that the greenhouse effect is
real despite what you may hear sometimes
the greenhouse effect is a real effect
on the left-hand side here it's a
reasonable place to start because we're
talking about human activity
anthropogenic as a fancy word for human
activity
anthropogenic and natural sources of
greenhouse gases and also aerosols which
I'll say something briefly about we are
adding these into the atmosphere and
then there are various natural sinks for
these chemical compounds these gases and
these particles in the atmosphere now
these gases have the important property
that they absorb infrared radiation that
radiates off from the surface of the
planet the planet can radiate energy to
space to make up for the input of energy
from the Sun and if it does that in
equal amounts then it can remain in an
equable and fairly equilibrium Kleiner
added to the complexity is the fact that
the ocean can take up some heat and on a
timescale of a hundred to a thousand
years can play a proof
roll in slowing down or speeding up the
amount of climate change that may be
occurring aerosols add a complexity
man-made aerosols and facts reflect
sunlight to space and that's the point
of the little piece of the cartoon on
your left-hand side this is useful I
think as a communication device that's
particularly useful I think to people
who have a little bit of scientific
training and know what infrared
radiation is most people know what solar
radiation is but so it is helpful and
it's one approach that that I found
useful in many audiences another one is
to actually show people some evidence of
past climate change people on the street
have heard about ice ages so another way
is to sneak in some science by showing
them a long term record of the ice ages
I hope this projects reasonably well at
the back but on the left-hand side of
this diagram is today and on the
right-hand side is 400,000 years ago
this information comes from drilling
into the Vostok area of Antarctica the
uppermost curve is the trace of carbon
dioxide levels in the ice core going
back to 400,000 years ago the middle
curve the red curve is the temperature
derived from the ice core and the lower
curve is methane concentrations derived
from the ice core and this is a good way
of telling people first the carbon
dioxide and methane of greenhouse gases
and for them to notice something that
there's a very strong correlation going
back 400,000 years between levels of
methane and carbon dioxide and
temperature such that the higher the
levels of these greenhouse gases the
higher the temperature I should
interject that that you can't explain
these climate changes by these
relatively small changes in the
greenhouse gases but at least this tells
the scientist there's a positive
feedback here that if you do warm the
world a bit you get more methane and
carbon dioxide that's worrisome climate
scientists do not like to discover
positive feedback but they exist in the
system so this tells you that the
greenhouse gases are certainly active
and the climate does change
and of course the cool times the dips
and these curves are the various ice
ages and you go back through time and
you see that we've had a variety of ice
ages this is the most recent then we had
the very warm period of the Eemian
another Ice Age another warm
interglacial an ice age a warm
interglacial and so on of course the
human influence on this diagram is very
small
we're just existing here at the point
here of the the very beginning of this
plot on the left hand side so this
doesn't tell us about the human
influence but at least it might help
convince the person on the street that
climate does change that it is not a
constant so then to do talk about things
closer to the present day it's useful
then to look at reconstructions of
temperature change and I want to go to
the one on the bottom first that says
the past 1000 years so now we're getting
a closer and closer focus on to today
two times this goes from the Year 1000
to the year 2000 and the blue curve that
you see there with the sort of light
blue shading around it is an attempt to
reconstruct temperatures from a variety
of proxy approaches from tree rings
corals ice cores of these probably the
ice cores are the most reliable and
those are the ones that provided the
record that I just showed you on the
previous graph if you believe the
central estimates here you'd say well
the world was cooling a very small
amount but clearly what's happened in
last 150 years is that we are rising way
out beyond this range of variability
that we saw in the past thousand years
and we're way up here now even if you
are skeptic and you want to believe that
that the blue here that I could start
here and have the best estimate going
from here over to here rather than in
this direction you would still reach the
strong conclusion that we seem to be
rising out of the noise of the system in
the last thousand years
you can quibble the way these are
reconstructed but if you believe this
information I've got in front of you you
do come to that conclusion
in other words that the world really is
warming up now if you focus in the last
140 years and look at more detail this
is now dependent on the thermometer
record so these are direct measures of
temperature there all sorts of
difficulties in the thermometer record
to do with spatial and temporal sampling
biases and you can imagine the southern
hemisphere being poorly covered in the
last century vast parts of the ocean
similarly nevertheless this is an
attempt best attempt around to
reconstruct what's gone on the last 140
years and again you see through to the
year 1900 it seems to have been rather
rather constant between 1900 and 1945 a
significant rise in temperature 1945 to
about 1970 or so it actually cooled a
little bit and then 1970 onwards
significant warming now there's a lot of
research going on in the past two or
three years in particular on trying to
work out what fraction of this warming
is due to human activity and what might
be due to natural activity and you can
imagine for that you've got to have some
idea of how the natural system works and
that proves to be a problem in this
research but there's little doubt in my
own mind that there is a human influence
on climate and it's evident in that
warming sequence I can't tell you what
the percentage is it might be only 10%
it might be 50% but it's there and you
get that conclusion from looking at the
pattern of the warming and seeing that
there are patterns of in the warming
that that what you might expect do to
agree rising greenhouse gases it still
remains a matter of controversy about
what the fraction of the warming we see
the warming is definitely there but the
fraction due to human influence is
debated so what do we do if we want to
forecast into the future if we're
convinced that at least humans have some
small influence on the system in 1990 I
was interested in this problem but then
I just quickly discovered something that
had me worried and that is to project
climate into the future I needed to know
about human activity in the future and
then I had to go talk to economist and
well it happened we we got together we
got a group here together and this is
just a cartoon to show you the various
elements of a global system model that
we put together
there's an economic model up here
there's a climate model here there's an
ecosystem model here and there's a model
of natural emissions of various
greenhouse gases over here and you can
see all the arrows going between them
this is a highly fed back system a great
deal of complexity in each of these
models and each of the models has great
uncertainty now it to do this type of
exercise and and to attempt to do what
we really wanted to do that is to get
our arms around the range of possible
outcomes
looking at the next hundred years it's a
big task and of course it requires an
unusual combination of intelligence
computer technology and arrogance and to
do this sort of thing
and those equalities that are often
found here at MIT sir so we we were in
good shape to do that sort of thing
first thing we did is we forecast seven
forecasts because three years ago we
didn't have the computer power that we
have today and so we decided we would do
seven forecasts we recognized from the
beginning that the economic models have
huge uncertainties right I thought
climate models won certain and I learned
further about uncertainties when I talk
to economists constructing their models
nevertheless we've made a very detailed
attempt to get our hands around those
uncertainties and for the climate model
model that we have here it's a highly
flexible model and has the advantage
that we can make sure that the various
versions of the model that we put in an
uncertainty analysis that they at least
can simulate the or slay within the
envelope of the temperature changes in
last hundred and forty years where we
have some idea of the greenhouse gas
emissions in that time so we can test or
make sure that the climate model
versions that we use at least give a
reasonable simulation of past climate
and so that's a constraint on the
process and this also enables me to
point something out that may not be
known to many of you and that is that if
you look at climate predictions from
from our climate model and many others
if this is the North Pole
and this is the South Pole here and this
is just degrees of temperature rise and
these are the
seven forecasts and the uppermost one
let's have a look at it it's labeled HHH
and the average temperature global
average temperature rise over the year
timeframe from 1990 to 2100 in this
forecast was about 5 degrees centigrade
but you'll notice it it's uneven across
the world an important thing is that
it's about 10 degrees centigrade in the
northern polar region and about 4
degrees centigrade in the tropics and
that focuses your attention on something
and say it's 10 degrees centigrade rise
in the polar regions believe me that's
something you should be deeply worried
about we have some big ice masses up
there we have tundra with great amounts
of carbon stored in it so you finally
begin by looking at some little bit more
detail here like predicting climate as a
function of latitude that may be this
this is a serious issue
however this diagram when you look at
these seven forecasts you could also
focus on the lowest curve alright and
say well look this is a feasible
forecast right you can justify the
various settings in the economic model
and the climate model that produced this
my answer when I went to when I and my
colleagues did this when we've talked
about it is it yeah we can justify the
assumptions made here or made here so
this was useful but at the end we
couldn't answer a question we were often
asked and that is what are the odds of
these rather extreme forecasts like this
was the one you worried about if if it's
anything down here maybe you know this
is not such a great concern but that's
the nature of the climate problem is
that if we admit the uncertainties that
exist in these forecasts then we get
this range but we can't talk about the
odds well I'd say at the beginning of
this year we finally completed what we
really wanted to do this is now very
tacky why what we wanted to do is
compute the probability distribution
function of the climate output and often
known as PDF now I should say I've been
doing these PDFs now for and concerned
with them for so much time now I get
excited when someone sends me an email
and said there's a PDF right and so many
times I've been so disappointed what was
the PDF one I thought it was one of the
what is the conclusion this is from 100
forecast now for those of you do
statistics it's it's we use a Latin
hypercube sampling technique that's a
way to get around having to do huge
numbers of Mario Monte Carlo simulation
but this was with 100 and then this is a
curve fit to the PD the discrete PDF
that you obtain and what's the
conclusion here it says that the median
temperature rise predicted for the next
hundred years is about two and a half
degrees centigrade corresponding to
about four or five degrees centigrade at
the pole right that's something to be
concerned about there's about a hair z
up a 95% bound 4.8 degrees centigrade so
there's about a chance in 41 chance in
40 have been greater than four point
eight degrees centigrade that helps you
calibrate the people who say it's going
to be the end of the world it's Tansen
40 that it's going to be big and it
helps you calibrate at the other end the
lower 95% bound was 0.9 degrees
centigrade so that says you know there's
a chance in 40 of being less than point
nine degrees centigrade so that helps
you calibrate the people that often
called naysayers the one that's the ones
that say this is a very small problem
well the nature of the issue is such
that you can't rule them out but at
least and now with this approach we can
give it some odds keep in mind that the
there's 50-50 chance then that the
temperature rise could be greater than
two and a half degrees centigrade now
then you want to use this this approach
and say well what if I enact a policy
designed to lower the emissions of
greenhouse gases how will it change the
shape of that and most importantly what
are the odds now of very significant
warming can I decrease the odds of very
significant warming that's what you want
to do with the policy you don't really
care about the the low end of the PDF so
this is recently being completed as well
and the actual numbers don't matter here
so much as the principle that we are
trying to get across with this approach
I should say by the way that this has
been done by a team of people and Mort
Webster who's I think here in the
audience
did a great deal of the work Chris
forest and and the usual collection of
more senior researchers have been
involved in this here's here is just a
sample policy it turns out to be a
policy of very stringent policy involves
all the countries of the world and I'd
say the chances of enacting such a
policy you know the Red Sox have a
greater chance of winning the World
Series than than us being elder and that
this particular policy in all other
countries in the world get on board and
and so on nevertheless it illustrates
what one would like to see in a policy
here is the old PDF that I just showed
you which said no policy here is the
range of temperature outcomes and then
the dashed line is with the policy and
so in this particular case the policy a
very stringent one interestingly the
it's be called beyond Kyoto case I won't
go through the details of what it is but
the beyond Kyoto case the upper 95%
bound is now two and a half degrees
centigrade that was a median value right
for the no policy case and so that was
50/50 chance of being greater than two
and a half degrees now with this policy
we're down to one chance and forty of
being greater than two and a half
degrees centigrade so if we could do
this and afford to do it and politically
it was possible then this would say
let's go and do it
of course I think all of you know the
hard facts of the politics of this issue
but at the end of the day if I showed
this in any audience other than you know
here at MIT and talked about pdf's eyes
would glaze over and again people would
confuse it with some attachment that
they've been sent by email it probably
wouldn't work so we finally after much
desperation and in discussion decided
that some sort of a Wheel of Fortune was
necessary and we've got one over here
and so I'm gonna pull it out now and I'm
gonna appeal to our illustrious
president of our institution here too
but before I do I want to explain what
he's going to do so you realize the
implications of this
yes there are a couple of no-shows as
you saw and Vanna was one of them and I
you know whatever happened I don't know
now let's look at the wheel the wheel
has been set up now according to the
probabilities not not of a hundred
forecasts but now of two hundred and
fifty forecasts so this is even more
more detail behind it and greater
accuracy in defining probabilities let's
just look at the wheel first and I want
to go at the top here I want you to
focus on these two ones at the top this
sort of very dark red color here says
greater than eight degrees Fahrenheit
that's bad news so if Chuck rolls this
and it ends up here that's bad news and
less than two degrees Fahrenheit means
the naysayers are there but the vast
rest of this circle here is goes from 2
to 3 3 to 4 degrees Fahrenheit 4 to 5 5
to 6 6 and 7 you'll notice something
I've done here I switched units because
another thing that's useless talking to
the public about in the United States is
degree centigrade their eyes glaze over
as well so it's in Fahrenheit another
important point to make here is a policy
would shrink the greater than 8 degrees
Fahrenheit and the 78 so these red
colors here the policy would shrink the
size of these and increase the size of
the blue the green and so on because
these are the lesser temperature rises
and that's what you'd want with the
policy and you see the effect of the
policy would to be to make it much less
less probable that chuck is going to
spin and land on the greater than 8
degrees Fahrenheit which is clearly one
we want to avoid so I think with that in
mind I'll just add that there the world
has one spin right because we've already
worked out the probabilities here the
probabilities have been worked out so
the world has one spin if we don't do
anything this is it this is the spin so
with that in mind I want you to move
over this side and you've got to give it
a good spin because if it doesn't go
around more than twice I'm gonna
it's gonna be biased and you're trying
to get you know you're trying to work
out how to land it so good
I have to remind you the press is
present I can see the headline tomorrow
MIT it looks like it's around three
degrees Fahrenheit Thank You Chuck I
think that's and the first is to thank
everybody whose name is on these two
sheets of paper we really appreciate all
that you did to make this day possible
and I actually mean that very much and
certainly do want to thank all of our
guests who spoke and who provided such
leadership to the nation over the years
I was asked to say a few words to
summarize today's discussions and I took
copious pages of notes but I think I
will spare you all of that and I just
wanted to walk through a few themes that
I believe I heard pretty clearly during
this day from our various speakers and
these are divided a little bit into
those which have very directly to do
with the functioning of the presidential
science advisor in the Office of Science
and Technology Policy and those that
perhaps represent broader issues and
challenges even than what goes on in
that part of the executive branch of our
government and if you'll bear with me
through that I'm going to present a
brief treatise on science and technology
policy in which I promise to answer the
most important question and science
policy and tell you what the most
important challenge is so let's begin
with some themes that I believe have
been present today first obviously in
this audience in this symposium a common
belief that the importance of science
and technology to our future in almost
every dimension is growing indeed
accelerating
and that meeting it is going to require
among other things a strong and
differently balanced federal budget for
science and technology but even more
fundamental I think is the juxtaposition
of this importance that we all ascribe
to advancing science and technology with
the reality that science is simply an
outlier in a highly political
environment in Washington second we
heard several times through this
wonderful historical dialogue on OSTP
and science advisors going all the way
back to bill golden and President Harry
Truman that the end of the day it's the
personal relationship coupled with
political realities that determine how
successful someone can be in that office
and the personal relationships
particularly with the president but also
as we heard several times with the
director of the Office of Management and
Budget and the ability of these folks to
pose things within the realm of
relevance to the administration's agenda
third we heard several times the age old
story that I think someday we're going
to have to figure out how to take to
heart which is that we have a very
fundamental problem in this country in
the fragmentation of our S&T budgets
into little pieces across different
appropriation committees within our
Congress and also I would put right
alongside with that this very important
term that was used of the perceived
utility of Science and Technology that
people in Congress and indeed in much of
the executive branch's enthusiasm for
investment in science is going to be
based on their perception of its utility
not an easy thing for many of us to
automatically
but undoubtedly a reality it also seemed
to me that there were some interesting
drifts and oscillations that went
through some of the historical talks
particularly the oscillation in
different historical periods further all
the science advisor between being in a
position where there ended up being a
single dominant issue and those who are
able to deal with a much broader
spectrum of S&T agenda items and also we
heard a bit about the drift in and out
of science and technology policy over
the years of the role of the private
sector as opposed to just the role of
the government and perhaps the
government and coupled with academia
this wonderful term of the citizen
scientist was used and whether or not
that term was used throughout the
discussions we heard over and over again
that we must bring science to the
government that we must in fact be
citizen scientists and explain the
importance of what we do how we do it
and what the consequences for good and
ill of what we do are we heard a plea a
couple of times for something that I
think many of us believe is is just
incredibly overlooked in this country
and that is a call for serious education
R&D or whatever terminology you want to
use that we have an industry that is
namely education that's most arguably
the most important societal function
that we take on for our young people and
we invest something less than a tenth of
a percent of its value into really
understanding how we learn and how we
can improve teaching and learning
dan Hastings was quite elegant in quite
eloquence he was
elegant also but he was quite eloquent
in reminding us that we need to develop
a far more integrated approach to
education and research particularly for
many of our engineers so that they can
bridge important gaps and can really
become the new leaders of an age that is
highly dependent on scientific and
technological knowledge for very
important decisions and finally I want
to end with what I would conclude if we
were to take a consensus among our
speakers are the two most important
issues going forward and the first is
the whole plethora of issues about our
science and engineering workforce in
this country and I think I hardly need
to expand on that because it was said so
many times and so many different ways
but meeting the challenges of the
scientific and engineering workforce and
as Jay Forrester reminded us the
effective and efficient use of that
workforce is one of perhaps the two most
dominant questions and the final one
which we heard from many people Phil
sharp this afternoon many of the other
speakers and certainly in a quite
wonderful and remarkable manner from
Harold Shapiro over lunch we must be
much more cognizant than we have been of
the set of moral and ethical issues that
are raised in a period of incredible
acceleration of scientific knowledge and
technological capability and that we
must understand at a much deeper level
the consequences of these advances for
our society and we must really
internalize the way in which they affect
people's anxieties and we must respond
to those through policy and through the
way we carry on public dialogue now
since you all were good enough to sit
through all of this I wanted to end
with pointing out this question and her
answer to a question and to pose a
challenge and we've had many people
you've heard from today who have written
entire area date books on science and
technology policy but being an engineer
I'm quite pragmatic fellow and I've
decided that the most important
practical question in science and
technology policy is how do you decide
what research what areas to fund with
finite resources I think the answer is
very simple you come to great
universities like this one and many
others across the country and you look
around and you ask the really bright
young people what they want to do and
that's where you ought to place your
money so that leaves us with the central
challenge of Science and Technology
Policy and I believe the grand challenge
that more or less subsumes most of what
we've talked about today is how do we
connect what congressman Porter referred
to as the perceived utility of science
to what these great young people want to
do with that let me thank again all the
participants and thank particularly the
sloan foundation for its support that
made this possible and all the wonderful
staff members from MIT and elsewhere who
rolled up their sleeves and made this
wonderful day possible for us and dan
again thank you very much for your
leadership and also to Duncan Moore who
had to leave just a little bit ago for
conceiving the whole thing
happy birthday OSTP
you